WE'RE
GONNA GO AHEAD AND GET STARTED
IF WE CAN HAVE EVERYONE TAKE
THEIR SEATS PLEASE. THIS IS
QUITE AN INCREDIBLE SHOWING.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
THIRTY SEVEN. SO WE'RE GONNA GO
AHEAD AND GET STARTED I WANT TO
FIRST THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING
HERE I WANT TO ALSO WELCOME ALL
OF YOU ADD TO OUR HEARING THIS
IS AN INFORMATIONAL HEARING WE
WILL NOT BE VOTING ON POLICY BY
HAVING A DISCUSSION ABOUT- THE
INTERSECTION OF EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS AND RESPONSE WITH
NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS- WITH
ME TODAY WE HAVE- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER AND CHAIR OF THE
GOVERNMENT GOVERNMENTAL
ORGANIZATION COMMITTEE ADAM
GRAY WHO IS VISITING US FROM
MODESTO. THANK YOU ADAM FOR
BEING HERE. SO THANK YOU ALL- I
ALSO WANT TO THANK OUR
PANELISTS YOU'RE GOING TO SEE A
VARIETY OF COMMUNITY PANELISTS
TO AND ORGANIZATIONAL PALATE-
PANELISTS THAT ARE HERE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THE IMPORTANT
DISCUSSION. AS THE CHAIR OF THE
SELECT COMMITTEE FOR THE
NONPROFIT SECTOR I'VE HAD THE
PRIVILEGE TO HIGHLIGHT THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF NON PROFITS-
AND WHAT THEY'RE DOING HERE IN
OUR STATE OF CALIFORNIA BUT WE
ALSO DISCUSSED SOME OF THE
CHALLENGES. THAT COME TO
NONPROFIT PARTICULARLY AROUND
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS IN
CALIFORNIA NONPROFIT ARE THE
FOURTH LARGEST INDUSTRY BY
EMPLOYMENT PRODUCE IN ONE OUT
OF EVERY FOUR. TEAM CALIFORNIA
JOBS. EVERY YEAR CALIFORNIA
NONPROFITS GENERATE TWO HUNDRED
EIGHT BILLION IN ANNUAL REVENUE
IMMOBILIZE THE EQUIVALENT OF
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE.
THOUSAND AND A FULL TIME JOB
DONE BY VOLUNTEERS. THE FEEDER
CHILDREN SHELTER HOMELESS AND
VIRTUALLY EVERY CRITICAL
CHALLENGE FACING US TODAY
DURING THE THOMAS FIRE AND THE
MONICA DEBRIS FLOW NONPROFIT.
ARE THE AUGMENT THE WIDE RANGE
OF COUNTY AND MUNICIPAL
SERVICES UTILIZING UNIQUE SKILL
SET AND THE TALENTS OF MANY
COMMITTED INDIVIDUALS THERE ARE
MANY NONPROFITS NOT ONLY ON THE
PANEL TODAY THAT PLAYED A KEY
ROLE IN DISASTER PREPAREDNESS
AND RESPONSE AND RECOVERY. THAT
IS WHY IN THIS HEARING IS SO
IMPORTANT I'M VERY GRATEFUL
THAT I CHAIRMAN A GRADE DECIDED
TO DO SOMETHING IN OUR
COMMUNITY. AS LOCAL AND STATE
EMERGENCY MANAGERS WORKING ON
PLANNING WITH NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS YOU KNOW FIRST
HAND HOW WE CAN EFFECTIVELY
PREPARE AND MOBILIZE THE WHOLE
COMMUNITY. YOU KNOW BUT HOW WE
CAN LEVERAGE NONPROFIT SECTOR
ASK THAT'S AS WELL AS
STRENGTHENING THE ABILITY TO
COORDINATE VOLUNTEERS AND
DONATIONS ON A REGIONAL BASIS I
LOOK FORWARD TO THE ENGAGING
CONVERSATION TO HEARING FROM
OUR PANELISTS. AND I AM GOING
TO ALLOW ASSEMBLY MEMBER AND
CHAIRMAN GREAT TO SAY A FEW
WORDS. GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME
EVERYONE THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE IT'S A PLEASURE TO JOIN MY
COLLEAGUE ASSEMBLYMEMBER
LAMONT. THE CHAIR OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON THE NONPROFIT
SECTOR. TODAY AS THE ROLE OF
NONPROFITS EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS. I KNOW THE PEOPLE
OF THE SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
LIKE MOST CALIFORNIANS OF
RECENT ARE NO STRANGER TO
ESTHER'S AND OUR THOUGHTS ARE
WITH ALL OF YOU DURING THE
UNRELENTING THOMAS FIRE IN THE
TRAGEDY OF THE MONTH TO CEDAR
MUD SLIDES WHEN IT COMES TO
THESE TYPES OF THAT DISASTERS
NO CITY OR COUNTY- IS AN ISLAND
THESE LARGE SCALE DISASTERS
UNDERSCORE THE IMPORTANCE OF
COORDINATION- OF WORKING
TOGETHER THE STATE'S MUTUAL
SYSTEM IN THE IDEAS. OF
NEIGHBORS HELPING NEIGHBORS
WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE HERE TO
DISCUSS TODAY. DISASTROUS CAN
CERTAINLY BRING OUT THE BEST IN
PEOPLE IS WERE CUT CUSTOM
HEARING STORIES OF HEROES AND I
MISS THE CHAOS OF WILD FIRES
AND OTHER NATURAL DISASTERS.
FAR TOO OFTEN THE PEOPLE
COMMUNITIES HIT HARDEST BY
DISASTERS OF THE MOST
VULNERABLE. WE KNOW NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATIONS CAN AND WILL IT
DO FILL CRITICAL UNMET NEEDS
DURING THE IMMEDIATE RESPONSE.
ASTERS THE LEGISLATURE THE
GOVERNOR RECENTLY INVESTED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS THE
URGENCY LEGISLATION AB SEVENTY
TWO. TO ESTABLISH THE
CALIFORNIA FOR ALL EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS CAMPAIGN AS A
JOINT EFFORT BETWEEN CALIFORNIA
VOLUNTEERS AND THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SERVICES.
TO ENHANCE DISASTER
PREPAREDNESS. I AM PLEASE WE
HAVE BAKER CALIFORNIA'S. EXCUSE
ME BAKER THE FORMER CHIEF
SERVICE OFFICER AND THE NEW
SENIOR ADVISER FOR DISASTER
VOLUNTEERING PREPAREDNESS A
CALLOW YES AND I'M EQUALLY
PLEASED TO SEE AN WELCOME ABBY
BROWNING CHIEF OF THE OFFICE OF
PRIVATE SECTOR AND NON COVER OF
COORDINATION CALLAWAY YES. AND
THANK YOU TO MISS EVER HEART OF
THE AMERICAN RED CROSS IN THIS
TOWER OF DIRECT RELIEF FOR
PARTICIPATING AS WELL THE LOCAL
OFFICIALS NONPROFITS WERE
ALWAYS ON THE LINES WHEN
DISASTERS STRIKE I LOOK FORWARD
TO HEARING FROM ALL THE TODAY
SO THAT WE CAN ALL BE BETTER
PREPARED TO. THANK YOU. SO WITH
LIKE TEN BY OUR PANELISTS TO
PLEASE COME UP WE HAVE ONE WHO
IS ALREADY SITTING HERE AND
WE'D LIKE TO INVITE THE OTHERS.
AT TO PLEASE COME UP. AND JUST
SO EVERYBODY KNOWS THIS IS
BEING LIVE STREAMED- THIS IS
THIS YOU CAN FIND THIS ON OUR
ASSEMBLY WEB PAGE. AND WE WILL
DO TWO PANELS- IN AFTER THE
PANEL WE WILL ALLOW FOR PUBLIC
COMMENT AND ONE MINUTE FOR
ANYONE WHO WOULD LIKE TO DO
PUBLIC COMMENT
. SO WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND HAVE YOU WILL BEGIN
WHO NEVER LIKE TO. THERE WE ARE
THANK YOU A GOOD MORNING
EVERYONE AS BEAUTIFUL DRIVE UP
HERE TO VISIT SANTA BARBARA CA
TAT MY NAME IS ABBY AND I AM
THE CHIEF OF THE OFFICE OF
PRIVATE SECTOR. NON
GOVERNMENTAL ORGANIZATION
COORDINATION FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES TAKE A
COUPLE BREATHS WHENEVER I SAY
THAT TITLE- BECAUSE IT IS A
VERY LONG TITLE BUT IT DOESN'T
REALLY AIMED ENCOMPASSES THE
THING THAT I DO I ALSO
COORDINATE WITH THE
UNIVERSITIES. WITH THE
PHILANTHROPIC ORGANIZATION WITH
THE COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS OF
VOLUNTEER ORGANIZATIONS AND-
FAITH BASED ORGANIZATIONS. I AM
NOT EXTERNAL AFFAIRS BUT WHAT I
DO IS I MAINTAIN RELATIONSHIPS
AND I A I LIKE TO CONSIDER
MYSELF THE CALLAWAY YES MATCH
MAKER. SO WHENEVER A NON PROFIT
COMES TO CALLOW YES AND WORKS
WITH US I MAKE SURE THAT THEY
ARE CONNECTED WITH THE EXPERTS
THAT DO WHAT THEY DO SO IT IS.
A SAY SHELTERING MASCARA
SHELTERING THEN THE RED CROSS.
I KIND OF MAKE SURE THAT DENISE
AND HER COLLEAGUES ARE
CONNECTED TO THE STATE
OFFICIALS THAT THAT WORK ON
THAT SUBJECT AS WELL AND- MAKE
SURE EVERYBODY'S PLAY. NICE IN
THE SANDBOX TOGETHER IT GETS.
KIND OF STRESSFUL DURING
DISASTERS AS YOU WOULD ALL
IMAGINE AND SO I I'D MEDIATE
AND I MAKE SURE THAT EVERYBODY
HAS THE SAME RESOURCES THAT
THEY NEED. IN ORDER TO SERVE
THE CALIFORNIANS THAT ARE BEING
AFFECTED BY THE DISASTER. SO
THAT'S THAT'S MY ROLE IN A VERY
SMALL NOT SHOW. BUT I THOUGHT I
WOULD GIVE A COUPLE EXAMPLES OF
HOW I HAVE- WORKED ON SOME OF
THE DISASTERS THAT WE'VE HAD IN
HOW THAT COORDINATION ROLE
HAPPENS AND THE VALUE OF IT. IN
TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE HAD THE-
LARGE NORTH BAY FIRES UP IN
CINEMA COUNTY. AND AT THE SAME
TIME THAT WE HAD- THE FIRED THE
THOMAS FIRE DOWN HERE. AS WELL
AS A FEW OTHER FIRES AND- I
BELIEVE IS ORANGE COUNTY. A IT
WAS A MASSIVE EFFORT AND IT WAS
REALLY TAXING ON ALL OF OUR NON
PROFITS UP AND DOWN THE STATE.
AND THEY WERE DOING EVERYTHING
THAT THEY COULD AND SOME OF
THESE NONPROFITS ARE- MASTERS
AT THEIR CRAFT. WHEN IT COMES
TO SHELTERING YOU GET OUT OF
THE WAY WHEN A FOR THE RED
CROSS TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY-
HAVE WHAT THEY DO BUT YOU JUST
GET OUT OF THEIR WAY AND LET
THEM DO THEIR JOB. SAME COMES
FOR FEEDING YOU KNOW WE HAVE. A
WORLD CENTRAL KITCHEN WE HAVE
THE- ADVENTIST WE HAVE A
SOUTHERN BAPTIST. ALL THESE
DIFFERENT ORGANIZATIONS THAT
THEY ARE EXPERTS AT MASS
FEEDING. AND SO WE GET OUT OF
THE WAY NOW AS YOU CAN IMAGINE.
DURING A DISASTER. EVERYBODY
ELSE WANTS TO HELP AND SO THEY
COME TO US AND THINK HOW DO WE
HELP HOW DO WE HELP. ONE OF THE
BIG ONES THAT WE HAD THAT CAME
TO US GOOGLE. AND WAS A. A
GRAND ME FOR CALIFORNIA AND WE
TALK TO THEM ABOUT. A MONETARY
DONATION THAT'S ALWAYS FAST AND
SO WE WERE ABLE TO SEND THEM TO
WHERE THEY NEEDED TO GO
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS WENT TO THE
DIFFERENT COMMUNITY FOUNDATIONS
IN THE COMMUNITIES THAT WERE
BEING AFFECTED. NORTHERN AND
SOUTHERN- WITHIN THEIR LIKE WE
WANT TO DO SOMETHING WANT TO DO
SOMETHING. THEY HAVE A FLEET OF
FOOD TRUCKS FANCY FOOD TRUCKS
BECAUSE THEY FEED ALL THEIR
GOOGLE LORS EVERY DAY. AND THEY
WANTED TO GIVE THEM AND SEND
THEM TO THE SHELTERS. THAT'S A
BIG NO NO. I'M LOOKING AT IT
GOING. I WOULD BE GREAT I THINK
THE SURVIVORS WOULD LOVE IT
BECAUSE THAT'S COOL RIGHT YOU
KNOW OKAY I HAVE TO DEAL WITH
SOMETHING AT LEAST I. HAVE A
COOL MEAL FROM A GOOGLE FOOD
TRUCK. BUT IT'S- ALL OF OUR NON
PROFITS ARE ALREADY THERE
PLANNING THIS ALL OUT. FIGURING
OUT HOW TO DO THE MEALS HOW DO
FOR THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE HOW TO
DO THIS HAVE TO DO THAT THEY'VE
GOT THE SUPPLIES. AND IF WE
BROUGHT IN A BUNCH OF FOOD
TRUCKS ALL THAT WOULD DO IS
MESS THEM UP THE LAST THING WE
WANTED TO DO. AND SO WHAT MARK
MY STAFF AND I WE HAD TO GET
CREATIVE AND THINK WELL HOW DO
WE DO THIS WHAT WE DO. SO WHAT
WE ENDED UP DOING WAS SENDING
THE FOOD TRUCKS TO THE LOCAL
ASSISTANCE CENTERS. WHEN PEOPLE
WERE STANDING IN LINE TO GET
THEIR SERVICES AND TO TALK TO
THEIR INSURANCE PEOPLE INTO THE
COUNTY FOLKS. THEY COULD HAVE A
FREE MEAL IF THEY WANTED TO
FROM THE GOODWILL TRUCKS AND SO
IT WAS KIND OF LIKE A WIN WIN.
BUT THAT'S WHY THE IMPORTANCE
OF MY OFFICE IS TO STOP THAT
KIND OF A MESS BECAUSE ALL THAT
WOULD HAVE DONE IS MAKE A
HEARTACHE FOR THE NON PROFITS
THAT WORK SO TIRELESSLY. TO DO
WHAT THEY'RE DOING SO THAT
THAT'S AN EXAMPLE OF HOW WE'RE
ABLE TO. COORDINATE THAT EFFORT
BECAUSE AT THE STATE LEVEL WE
WHERE WE CAN SEE EVERYTHING
THAT'S GOING ON. AND WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND MAKE SURE THAT
THE BEST IS THERE. SO ONE OTHER
THING I WANTED TO MENTION ABOUT
CALLOW YES THAT'S BEYOND ME. IS
WE HAVE AN AMAZING TEAM THAT'S
GRANTS MANAGEMENT. AND WE
HANDLE THE HOMELAND SECURITY
GRANTS AND EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
GRANTS FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THEN WE TURN
AROUND. AND HAND THOSE OUT.
BASED TO THE LEVEL OF LOCAL
COMMUNITIES YOU KNOW WE SO THEY
CAN BY FIRE TRUCKS THEY CAN BY
POLICE CARS THEY CAN DO ALL
THAT KIND OF- PUBLIC SAFETY
THINGS. BUT ALSO PART OF THAT
IS WE HAVE THE VICTIMS
COMPENSATION. AND THE- VICTIM
SERVICES. GRANTS AND WE SUPPORT
OUR NON PROFITS FOR THAT IT'S A
VERY IMPORTANT THING TO DO-
BECAUSE AS WE'VE SEEN AND YOU
ALL KNOW FIRST HAND. ARE
DISASTERS ARE BECOMING MORE AND
MORE VIOLENCE. THERE ARE MORE
MENTALLY TAXING AND DRAINING.
AND SO WE NEED- OF MORE
COUNSELORS AND MORE CRISIS
COUNSELORS. AND THAT'S THE NON
PROFITS THAT STEP UP INTO THAT
ROLE. AS A WE HAVE BEEN TRYING
TO PREPARE THEM FOR THE
DISASTERS. BY FUNNELING MONEY.
INTO THOSE NONPROFITS TO BRING
THAT INFORMATION UP SO THAT'S A
PROGRAM THAT WE HAVE. AS WELL
TO ASSIST THE NONPROFITS SO.
THAT'S MARI SEVEN MINUTES AND I
WILL BE HERE TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS AND I'M ALWAYS HERE.
SO IF YOU SEE ME AND YOU
HAVEN'T QUESTION BY ALL MEANS
FIND BE AFTERWARDS THAT I CAN
ANSWER THEM. THANK YOU. OKAY
THANK YOU. AT THIS TIME WE'LL
HEAR FROM ABIGAIL BROWN.
ACTUALLY NO EXCUSE ME I SKIPPED
OVER CARE BAKER. WELL THANK YOU
SO MUCH I CAN'T APPLY DO ENOUGH
FOR THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
HEARING I THINK IS THIS FULL
ROOM REALLY SHOWS THERE ARE
MORE PASSIONATE PEOPLE IN THIS
ROOM THAT CARE ABOUT- VERY
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS IN THEIR
COMMUNITY THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
ON THE FRONT LINES UP AND I
JUST WANNA I KNOW ON BEHALF OF
EVERYONE HERE JUST THANK.
EVERYONE FOR THEIR EFFORTS AND
THEIR PASSION AND THEIR CARE-
IT MATTERS AND I'M JUST SO
GRATEFUL FOR THIS HEARING HI TO
SHINE A LIGHT ON THE IMPORTANT
CONTRIBUTION THAT EVERYONE IN
THIS ROOM IS MAKING IN THIS
SPACE- I AM OF A SENIOR ADVISER
HELLO YES NEWLY APPOINTED TO CO
CHAIR OF THE LEASE DOES
CALIFORNIA CAMPAIGN. WHICH IS
THE EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS
CAMPAIGN A FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
CAMPAIGN ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY
SPOKE OUT- AND IS THE ARCHITECT
OF THAT CAMPAIGN I JUST THOUGHT
I'D TAKE A FEW MINUTES TO
EXPLAIN THE COMPONENTS OF THE
CAMPAIGN- AND THEN ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE- THIS
WAS ANNOUNCED BY GOVERNOR
NEWSOME I THINK. PROBABLY THE
DAY AFTER HE WAS SWORN IN AND
BECAUSE IT WAS SUCH AN
IMPORTANT PRIORITY TO BOTH HE
AND THE LEGISLATURE TO REALLY
ENSURE THAT ARE MORE MOST
DIVERSE AND VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS REALLY ARE READY
FOR WILD FIRES EARTHQUAKES AND
FLOODS. AND SO A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS WAS SET ASIDE IN THIS
TRAILER BILL AND- I WORKED WITH
THE GOVERNOR'S TEAM AND
LEGISLATURE TO REALLY SORT OUT
WHAT ARE THE STRATEGIES FOR
PUTTING OUT MONEY TO WORK SO I
WANTED TO KIND OF EXPLAIN OUT
WHERE THAT MONEY IS AT WORK-
FIRST OF ALL WE DECIDED TO
TARGET SIX COUNTIES. TO IN THE
NORTH TO CENTRAL AND TWO IN THE
SOUTH THAT WE KNEW WE NEEDED
IMMEDIATE ASSISTANCE IT
INCLUDED SHASTA LAKE FRESNO
TULARE. SAN BERNARDINO AND
RIVERSIDE COUNTIES. AND THEN
WHAT WE SAID ALL OTHER COUNTIES
THAT YOU MAY APPLY. FOR THE
REMAINING DOLLARS AND WE WERE
ABLE TO FIND EIGHTEEN
ADDITIONAL COUNTIES SO WE HAVE
TWENTY FOUR COUNTIES. THAT ARE
AT THE CENTER OF THIS
INITIATIVE RECOGNIZING THAT WE
HAVE OTHER INVESTMENTS OUT OF
THE FIFTY MILLION THAT BENEFIT
THE WHOLE STATE AND I'LL BE
ABLE TO CLARIFY THAT IN A
SECOND- THE THING IS I THINK
REALLY EXCITING ABOUT IT IS THE
ENTIRE FIFTY MILLION. WENT OUT
TO NON PROFITS THAT'S WHERE THE
MONEY- LANDED SO- WHETHER IN
SAN BERNADINO AND YOU'RE THE
ORGANIZATION AL SOUL. WHO WORKS
PRIMARILY WITH THE LATINO
COMMUNITY YOU WERE THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT RECEIVED
THESE DOLLARS AND THEN YOU ARE
IN A POSITION WHERE YOU SUB
GRANTS. TO OTHER NON PROFITS
THAT WORK WITH OTHER PRIORITY
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS SO WHAT
ARE THOSE POPULATIONS THOSE ARE
SENIORS. AS A PEOPLE
DISABILITIES NON ENGLISH
SPEAKERS MIGRANT UNDOCUMENTED-
MEMBERS OF TRIBES- ALL POP
PEOPLE IN POVERTY. THE REST
SOCIALLY ISOLATED THESE ARE THE
INDIVIDUALS THAT OFTEN GET
CAUGHT AND CAN'T GET OUT. SO
THE WHOLE OBJECTIVE IS TO
REALLY BE SURE THAT WE CAN
EDUCATE THESE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS WITH THE DOLLARS
THAT ARE SPENT ON A PUBLIC
EDUCATION CAMPAIGN. SO SOME OF
THE DOLLARS ARE SET ASIDE FOR
COMMUNICATION- INVESTMENT SO
CURRICULUM- AND IT'S GIVEN IN
SIX DIFFERENT LANGUAGES ENGLISH
SPANISH VIETNAMESE KOREAN AND
TAGALOG. ARMENIAN CHINESE THESE
ARE THE SIX MOST FREQUENTLY
SPOKEN LANGUAGES IF YOU DON'T
SPEAK ENGLISH HERE IN IN
CALIFORNIA ANOTHER SIGNIFICANT.
INVESTMENT WENT TO BUILDING OUT
OUR VOLUNTEER AND SERVICE TEAM
ASSETS IN OUR STATE YOU KNOW
SANTA BARBARA IS HOME TO ONE OF
THE MOST INSPIRING PROGRAMS
THESE DOES CALIFORNIA LILIANA
IN THE HOUSE. AND JUST WANNA
AND CONGRATULATE YOU FOR YOUR
INNOVATION THIS IS A PHENOMENAL
EIGHT OUR FAMILY PREPAREDNESS-
A TRAINING THAT IS OFFERED IN
SPANISH- THE WILL TRANSLATED IN
OTHER LANGUAGES SO- WHAT WE DID
DO IS ALSO DEDICATE SOME OF THE
FUNDS TO GROW THE LEASE DOES
PROGRAM MODEL IN. UP TO SIXTY
DIFFERENT MARKETS WERE AND
THAT'S THROUGHOUT THE STATE NOT
JUST LIMITED TO THE TWENTY FOUR
COUNTIES AND ALSO GROW SEARCH
COMMUNITY EMERGENCY RESPONSE
TEAMS DOWN OUR FIRE SAFE
COUNCILS WILL BE PUT TO WORK.
WITH EDUCATING- OFFERING THEIR
CURRICULUM AND- COUNTY SO WE'RE
VERY EXCITED ABOUT THAT
INVESTMENT. FINALLY I THINK THE
THING THAT'S REALLY INTERESTING
IS THE WHOLE CAMPAIGN IS A
PEOPLE CENTERED CAMPAIGN BUT
IT'S INFORMED BY DATA. UP FOR
THE FIRST TIME WHAT WE'VE DONE
IS OVERLAPPED- HAZARD DATA AND
CREATED HEAT MAPS WITH
DIFFERENT SOCIAL VULNERABILITY
POPULATIONS SO THAT YOU CAN
LOOK OUT OF ANY GIVEN COUNTY
AND THIS IS BEEN DONE FOR ALL
FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES. SO YOU
CAN LOOK HERE IN SANTA BARBARA
AND LOOK AT WHAT NICHE OF SANTA
BARBARA IS AT RISK FOR
EARTHQUAKE. WHAT IS AT RISK FOR
FLOODING IF THAT WERE AN ISSUE
FOR- WILD FIRES AND THEN BE
ABLE TO LOOK AT WELL WE'RE TO
OUR SENIORS LIVE AND WHERE TO
OUR- MIGRANT COMMUNITY LIVE.
AND BE ABLE TO THEN DO A VERY
TARGETED CAMPAIGN RIGHT IN THAT
IN THAT COMMUNITY. SO BY HAVING
KIND OF THIS DATA SCIENCE
REALLY LEADING AND ARE
DESIGNED- ALONG WITH THE
STRENGTH OF TRUSTED BROKERS
THAT ARE IN THE NONPROFIT
COMMUNITY FAITH BASED AS WELL
AS OTHER NON PROFITS I THINK
WERE ABLE TO LIKE CAPITALIZE.
ON THOSE RELATIONSHIPS THAT
THEY HAVE WITH THEIR BABIES AND
REALLY MAKE SURE WE GET ARE
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES REALLY
EDUCATED. AND PREPARE. AND
WITHOUT A JUST BUT YOU ASK ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT HAVE.
THANKS I THINK WE'LL GET
THROUGH THE ENTIRE PANEL SURE I
WILL OPEN UP FOR SOME QUESTIONS
AT THAT POINT SO- WILL TURN
OVER TO DENISE FOR. THE
PRESENTATION THANK YOU GOOD
MORNING I DON'T HAVE A
PRESENTATION I'D DENISE EVER
HARD ON THE DIVISION DISASTER
EXECUTIVE FOR THE PACIFIC
DIVISION FOR THE AMERICAN RED
CROSS. SO MY TERRITORY IF IT'S
THE STATE A COMMONWEALTH OR
TERRITORY IN IT TOUCHES THE
PACIFIC OCEAN. I'M RESPONSIBLE
FOR PREPARING RESPONDING AND
RECOVERING TO DESERVE TO
DISASTERS. THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WERE BROKEN INTO SIX
REGIONS AND THAT WAY WE HAVE
RED CROSSERS IN COMMUNITIES ALL
THROUGHOUT THE STATE RESPONDING
EVERY DAY HELPING PEOPLE
PREPARE EVERY DAY. AND STAYING
THERE THROUGHOUT THE LONG TERM
RECOVERY WE ARE A 90% VOLUNTEER
ORGANIZATION SO ON DISASTERS WE
ARE ALSO VERY MUCH A VOLUNTEER
ORGANIZATION. WE'VE ALSO BEEN
WORKING WITH CAL CAL VOLUNTEERS
ON A CALIFORNIA COURT PROGRAM
WHERE WE HAVE PEOPLE THAT ARE
WORKING IN THESE REGIONS EVERY
SINGLE DAY. WORKING ON
PREPAREDNESS NOW FOR US
PREPAREDNESS IS NOT JUST
PREPAREDNESS FOR DISASTERS
NUMBER ONE DISASTER WE GO ON
EVERY DAY IS A HOME FIRE. AND
SO WE'VE USED THAT THAT
DISASTER AND OUR EFFORTS AROUND
THAT TO INFORM THE LARGER
DISASTER PREPAREDNESS SO WHAT
WE'VE DONE IS WE'VE ALSO MAPPED
OUT THE VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
AND WE'RE FOCUSING ON THOSE
AREAS BY INSTALLING SMOKE
ALARMS THE ADVANTAGE OF
INSTALLING A SMOKE ALARM IS
YOU'RE BRINGING SOMETHING TO
THEM THEY INVITE US INTO THEIR
HOUSE. AND THEN WE CAN SIT DOWN
AND TALK ABOUT THE LARGER
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS- WE ARE
TARGETING AND- TWO DIFFERENT
TYPES OF POPULATION. SOCIAL YOU
VULNERABLE AND AS WELL AS
ENGLISH AS A SECOND LANGUAGE-
AND SO WE'RE DOING A LOT OF
EFFORTS AROUND THAT. TO REALLY
TRY AND HELP THOSE POPULATIONS
GET PREPARED. AS FAR AS
DISASTERS GO EVERYBODY KNOWS
THAT THE RED CROSS THAT
SHELTERING. I THINK EVERYBODY
KNOWS IF YOU DON'T YOU KNOW
NOW- AND WE ARE OFTEN THE FIRST
LINE OPENING SHELTERS IN MIGHT
BE AN EVACUATION CENTER JUST
WHEN PEOPLE HAVE TO LEAVE THEIR
HOMES WITH NO NOTICE AND FIND A
PLACE TO STAY. OR A LONGER TERM
SHELTER I WILL TELL YOU THE
DISASTERS ARE CHANGING. WE KEEP
SEEING THIS IS THE LARGEST
WILDFIRE WE'VE EVER SEEN IT'S
THE MOST ACREAGE IT'S THE MOST
FATALITIES IT'S THE MOST LOS
HOMES. WE'RE ALSO SEEING A
HOUSING SHORTAGE IN THE STATE.
AND AS A RESULT WE'RE
SHELTERING LONGER. WE DO OTHER
THINGS IN OUR SHELTERS AND WE
DO OTHER THINGS AS PART OF OUR
RESPONSE WERE PART OF THE WHOLE
COMMUNITY EFFORT. SO WE ALSO DO
FEEDING. OR WE WORK WITH
PARTNERS TO DEFEATING I THINK
ABBY MENTIONED SOME OF THEN THE
SALVATION ARMY WORLD CENTRAL
KITCHEN WE HAVE PARTNERS. WHO
STEP IN AND HELP AT THE STATE
WHAT WE DO IS WE PUT TOGETHER
WHAT IS CALLED THE TASK FORCE.
AND OFTEN TIMES THE DIFFERENT
AGENCIES WILL GRAB A ROLE IN
THE TASK FORCE WE GRAB
SHELTERING SALVATION ARMY ON
THE LAST ONE GRAM FEEDING- AND
WE KIND OF. PARSE OUT THE WORK.
BIG DISASTERS OF ALSO CHANGE
BECAUSE OF SOCIAL MEDIA. IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN WHEN WE
RESPONDED. TO THE FIRES- I'LL
BE HONEST THE SOCIAL MEDIA OUT
LACKS WE HAD ON UNSOLICITED
DONATIONS AND THE USE OF
VOLUNTEERS WAS REALLY A
STRUGGLE FOR US WE CHANGED OUR
POLICIES. SO NOW WHEN PEOPLE DO
BRING UNSOLICITED DONATIONS THE
STUFF FROM YOUR CLOSET TO A
SHELTER WE PUT IT IN A BOX
TRUCK AND WE TRY AND FIND A
PARTNER. TO HELP US SORT AND
WASH AND PUT THAT THOSE THINGS
BACK INTO THE COMMUNITY WHERE
THEY NEED THEM SAME THING WITH
VOLUNTEERS A LARGE PART OF OUR
RESPONSE LAST YEAR TO THE
CAMPFIRE. WAS WHAT WE CALL
INVENT BASE VOLUNTEERS PEOPLE
WHO SAID I SEE THIS AWFUL
DISASTER I WANT TO HELP AND SO
OUR GOAL IS TO REALLY TRY AND
BRING THEM IN THE DOOR AND PUT
THEM TO WORK. THAT WAY THE
WHOLE COMMUNITY IS INVOLVED IN
COMMUNITIES DO FEEL LIKE THEY
HAVE A PIECE OF THIS DISASTER.
ONE OF THE GREAT THINGS TO COME
OUT OF THE LAST FEW YEARS OF
DISASTERS IS. AND IN SOME WAY
WITH ABBY'S HELP WE'VE GOTTEN
BETTER AT IT- BUT WE'VE BEEN
ABLE TO WORK WITH OUR
GOVERNMENT PARTNERS TO SEE.
WHAT DISASTER COSTS COULD BE
REFUNDABLE BY FEMA. AND KIND OF
SHIFT SOME OF THOSE THINGS OVER
TO THE STATE AND THE STATE WAS
DOING THOSE THAT ENABLED US TO
PUT A LOT MORE MONEY INTO LONG
TERM RECOVERY. SO WE'RE WORKING
IN THE COMMUNITY IS STILL ON
THE TWENTY EIGHTEEN FIRES WERE
ACTUALLY STILL WORKING ON SOME
OF THE TWENTY FIFTEEN FIRES.
BUT WE'RE DOING NOT ONLY FUNDS
FOR INDIVIDUALS BUT GRANTS TO
COMMUNITIES AND TRYING TO HELP
THEM BUILD UP THEIR CAPACITY TO
RECOVER FROM DISASTERS. AND
THEIR ABILITY TO CHANGE THE
FACE OF NOT ONLY DISASTER
RESPONSE BUT DISASTER RECOVERY
IN THEIR COMMUNITIES AS PART OF
THAT WERE WORKING CLOSELY WITH
THE VOLUNTARY ORGANIZATIONS
ACTIVE IN DISASTERS. AND
SETTING UP LOCAL LONG TERM
RECOVERY COMMITTEES. YOU KNOW
LAST YEAR DURING THE CAMP FIRE
THAT WAS A REAL STRUGGLE FOR US
WE SHELTERED FOR NINETY NINE
DAYS. THE RED CROSS THAT THAT
IS NOT OUR MODEL TO SHELTER FOR
NINETY NINE DAYS NOT JUST
BECAUSE IT'S HARD FOR US TO DO
AND HARD FOR ALL OF OUR
PARTNERS BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY.
BECAUSE IT'S HARD FOR THE
PEOPLE AFFECTED BY DISASTERS
AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING IN WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO NEED TO START
LOOKING AT IS WITH THE HOUSING
SHORTAGE IN THIS STATE. WHEN
PEOPLE LOSE THEIR HOME WHEN A
TOWN LIKE PARADISE LEASES
FIFTEEN THOUSAND HOMES WHAT IS
THE SOLUTION. NORMALLY WE FIND
MY A RENTAL OR ANOTHER HOUSE
THEY GET INSURANCE AND THEY
MOVE ON WE HAD PEOPLE WHO COULD
NOT FIND A NEW PLACE TO LIVE-
AND THEY STAYED IN OUR SHELTERS
AND SAID THAT IS WHAT IS GOING
TO TAKE A WHOLE COMMUNITY THAT
THAT'S THE OTHER PART OF THE
DISASTERS THAT I DO THINK WE
NEED TO FOCUS ON- BUT THE
PREPAREDNESS PART. IS ALSO
GOING TO HELP THIS THE MORE WE
CAN GET PEOPLE TO. HAVE THE
SUPPLIES THEY NEED TO EVACUATE
THE MORE WE CAN GET PEOPLE TO
HAVE THE INSURANCE THEY NEED TO
RECOVER AND TO HAVE A PLAN THE
BETTER OFF WE ARE AND THAT'S
WHERE THIS PARTNERSHIP HIS IS
REALLY GOING TO HELP US CHANGE.
THAT FACE OF DISASTER. THANK.
THANK YOU ARE AND I WILL HEAR
FROM OUR LAST ANALYST WITH
DIRECT RELIEF. EXCUSE ME I
EVERYONE- THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS OF THE MONNING GRAY FOR
HAVING US I REALLY APPRECIATE
THE OPPORTUNITY I THINK IT'S A
PERFECT SEGUE FOR US AS- THE
RED CROSS IS GREAT WORK-
PROVIDING- HUMAN SUPPORT-
VOLUNTEERS- IN PARTICULAR AND
FROM DIRECTLY CAMP POINT WHERE
A MEDICAL RELIEF ORGANIZATIONS
SO WE BRING. A RESOURCES
ASSOCIATED WITH HEALTH NEEDS-
WERE FOUNDED IN SANTA BARBARA-
FOR THOSE OF YOU TO ADD THE
DON'T KNOW WE'VE BEEN AROUND
ABOUT SEVENTY YEARS AND OUR
PRINCIPAL FOCUS IS ENGAGING
WITH- MEDICAL MANUFACTURES-
HEALTH CARE INDUSTRY TO RECEIVE
DONATED MEDICINE SUPPLIES. AND
OTHER- MEDICAL GOODS AT OUR
FACILITY HEARING TO LEAD TO AN
INTER DEPLOY THOSE TWO
PROVIDERS ALL AROUND THE GLOBE
WE WERE IN ABOUT A HUNDRED
COUNTRIES AROUND THE WORLD. AND
THEN WITHIN THE UNITED STATES
ALL FIFTY UNITED STATES- AROUND
THE PROVISION OF HEALTH
SERVICES- TYPICALLY VIA-
FEDERALLY QUALIFIED HEALTH
CENTER SCREENSHOT OF A CLINICS
AND PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS.
SO I THINK I THIS PANEL WAS
PERFECT WE'VE LONG WORKED- IN
CALIFORNIA SINCE OUR INCEPTION-
AND WITH ABBY AND HER TEAM AT-
CALLOW YES REALLY AS AN ENTITY
THAT WORKS TO LEVERAGE THE
DONATIONS FROM- INDUSTRY AND
ENCOURAGE THE- SORT OF
PARTICIPATION AMONG PRIVATE
INDUSTRY TO. PROVIDE
HUMANITARIAN RELIEF SERVICES- I
CAN TALK ABOUT A COUPLE OF
QUICK EXAMPLES- TO THAT AND ON
THE NETWORK THAT WE'VE BUILT
OUT IN CALIFORNIA IT'S ABOUT
SIX HUNDRED- CARE PROVIDERS
AGAIN THOSE CLINICS HEALTH
CENTERS IN PUBLIC HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS- THEY IN TURN
BASICALLY ARE ABLE TO- BE
APPROVED TO RECEIVE SUPPORT
FROM DREXEL LEAF WHICH REQUIRES
AN APPLICATION AND VETTING
PROCESS OF THEIR MEDICAL
LICENSE. AND THEN DEMONSTRATION
THAT THEY'RE PROVIDING CARE TO
OF HONORABLY- ARE VULNERABLE
MEDICAL POPULATION ON AN
ONGOING BASIS SO THAT WHEN A
PERSON SEES HAPPEN- WE ALREADY
HAVE AN ESTABLISHED
RELATIONSHIP A CONTACT OF TOUCH
POINTS IN A COMMUNITY THAT'S
AFFECTED- SO MOST RECENTLY FOR
INSTANCE IN A FEW COUNTY- WITH
THE CAMPFIRE WE HAD EXISTING
RELATIONS. WITH THE HEALTHCARE
PROVIDERS THERE FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS WHEN THE FIRES BROKE OUT-
OUR GOAL THEN WAS. LIFE ANY
MEDICAL RESOURCES THAT WERE
NEEDED FOR THEIR RESPONSE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE MEDICAL
SHELTERS- FIRST BY CONTACTING
OUT BEING HELLO YES AS A MEMBER
OF THE BUSINESS OPERATION
CENTER THAT WE'VE BEEN A PART
OF FOR A NUMBER OF YEARS. AND
THEN THOSE EXISTING HEALTH CARE
ENTITIES. OUR GOAL IS TO
ESTABLISH THAN WHAT THOSE
MEDICAL NEEDS ARE AND THEN TO
TRY TO LEVERAGE THOSE
DONATIONS- FROM- INDUSTRY. SO
WE'RE ABLE TO PROVIDE- COUPLE
HUNDRED THOUSAND AND NINETY
FIVE MASS OF OXYGEN
CONCENTRATORS NEBULIZERS
INHALERS- AND THEN WHEN THE
MEDICAL SHELTERS FORMED- GIVEN
THE- AMOUNT OF EVACUATIONS-
THAT OCCURRED- WE'RE AVAIL.
ABLE TO EQUIP WITH- MEDICAL
KITS- OUR HEALTH KIDS TO COUNTY
HEALTH- PROFESSIONALS- ALL THE
RESOURCES THAT THEY NEEDED TO
PROVIDED HEALTH CARE- FOR THAT
SEVERAL WEEK PERIOD IN THE- THE
INITIAL RECOVERY EFFORTS- SO
THAT'S- KIND OF ONE EXAMPLE.
HERE IN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY-
WE HAVE A LONG TIME
RELATIONSHIP WITH- SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH IS
PART OF THAT YES AT EIGHT
FUNCTION OUR WORK WITH- THAT-
EM- WERE REALLY AGAIN. HELPING
TO BOLSTER AND ANY LOCAL EVENT
THAT OCCURS AND ACCESS
RESOURCES ON BEHALF OF. I
COUNTY OFFICIALS AND OTHER
LOCAL NGOS. SEIZES WE COULD
TRYING TO LEVERAGE ANY FUNDING
THAT- CAME OUR WAY AND THEN
ALSO WITH MEDICAL MATERIAL-
NAMELY DO A QUICK PEOPLE WHO
WERE GOING BACK INTO THEIR
HOMES FOR THE FIRST TIME AFTER
THE DEBRIS FLOW WITH PROTECTIVE
SUITS GLOVES GOGGLES. MASKS
THINK THAN THEY NEEDED TO
BECOME SAFE WE ALSO WERE ABLE
TO- ACCESS VACCINES TO ENSURE
EVERYBODY WAS VACCINATED IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE PUBLIC
HEALTH DEPARTMENT- AS THEY WENT
BACK IN- TO- THEIR HOMES. AND I
THINK LASTLY WHAT WE'VE SEEN A
LARGER ROLE IN- THAT PUBLIC
PRIVATE- PARTNERSHIP IN
CONNECTION IS SUPPORT OF LOCAL
FIRST RESPONDERS- HERE IN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY IN ADDITION TO
BUTTE AND INTER COUNTY- I THINK
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'VE
SEEN AS AN ORGANIZATION IS THAT
WILLINGNESS TO HELP. AND AS
ABBIE REFERENCE CASH IS A
REALLY GREAT WAY TO QUICKLY
MOVING TO PROVIDE THOSE REALLY
SPECIFIC RESOURCES THAT. FOLKS
NEED AND WE RECOGNIZE HERE IN
OUR OWN COMMUNITY- SOME ARE
LOCAL FIRST RESPONDERS DIDN'T
HAVE THE TOOLS THAT THEY NEEDED
TO RESPOND TO SOMETHING.
BECAUSE OF SOMETHING YOU REALLY
COULD NEVER FOR CAT HAVE
FORECAST WHAT HAPPENS RIGHT. SO
WE PURCHASED NUMBER OF
VEHICLES- ATVS SEARCH AND
RESCUE YEAR- AND TRY TO
BASICALLY PROVIDE A PIPELINE
FOR PRIVATE DONATIONS INTO. A
QUICK- LOCAL FIRST RESPONDERS-
AND THEN I THINK VERY LASTLY-
THIS IS SORT OF A STANDING
INVITATION FOR ANYBODY HERE TO
COME VISIT US. WE HAVE A BRAND
NEW FACILITY THAT WAS PURPOSE
BUILT- FOR OUR ORGANIZATION AND
REALLY WE SEE IT AS A PUBLIC
ASSET- THAT'S RUN BY A
NONPROFIT. IT'S A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT
WAREHOUSE- FACILITY IT'S THE
ONLY ONE THAT THE ST STE IN THE
UNITED STATES AS A NONPROFIT
WHOLESALE PHARMACY. UP FOR WHAT
WE DO HAVE A- CALL THAT WE
REFERRED AT. ALL IT'S A
BASICALLY COMMUNITY ORGANIZING-
SPACE THAT WE CAN USE TO HOST
EVENTS. MEETINGS THINGS OF THAT
NATURE SO ANYBODY HERE. THAT
NEEDS TO THAT- SPACE PLEASE.
LET US KNOW AND THEN IN
ADDITION I THINK RELATED TO
THIS NEW ENVIRONMENT OR IN.
THOSE WITH POWER LOSS
PARTICULAR- WE HAVE NINE
HUNDRED NINETY NINE SOLAR POWER.
AND THEN A GENERATOR WE
BASICALLY STOPS A LITTLE MICRO
BREAD- WHICH IS IN ABILITY THAN
FOR US TO STAY ON WITH POWER
DURING ANY EVENT THE IDEA BEING
THAT THE PANELS CAN CHARGE
DURING THE DAY AND THEN IF WE
NEED TO TAP A DIESEL GENERATOR
TO RUN I WE CAN AND THE PURPOSE
THERE'S TO ENSURE THAT WE CAN
STAY OPERATIONAL TO REALLY
SUPPORT- STATE AND LOCAL NEEDS
ASSOCIATED WITH- MAJOR EVENTS-
SO AGAIN STANDING INVITATION TO
COME VISIT AND I JUST WANTED TO
SAY THANK YOU AGAIN FOR
ALLOWING US THE OPPORTUNITY TO.
BE PART OF THIS PANEL. Q. I
APPRECIATE ALL OF THE FEEDBACK
AND- THAT THE PRESENTATIONS AND
INFORMATION I HAVE ONE QUESTION.
IT SOUNDS LIKE A- REGRETTABLY
WE'VE HAD A LOT OF EXPERIENCE
THEM MORE RECENTLY OR OVER THE
YEARS BUT ONE OF THE QUESTIONS.
THAT STILL RISES IN IN THE
MOMENTS IS HOW HOW DOES A
COMMUNITY DETERMINE THE
SPECIFIC ROLES OF RESPONSE- IS
THERE ANYTHING BEING DONE IN-
IN THAT SPACE THAT YOU CAN
THINK OF. AND SO IN THIS MOMENT
WERE NICE WERE CALM WE ALL KNOW
EACH OTHER'S ROLES. IT'S BEEN
MY EXPERIENCE THAT TO A
PARTICULAR IN THE FIRST FORTY
EIGHT TO. YOU KNOW FORTY EIGHT
HOURS TO WEEK IT'S KIND OF LIKE
WHO'S DOING WHAT DEPENDING YOU
KNOW THERE'S JUST SOME
QUESTIONS ARE THERE GREATER
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT IDENTIFYING
SPECIFIC ROLES BETWEEN NON
NONPROFIT AND GOVERNMENT
AGENCIES. UP PARTICULARLY TO
MAXIMIZE- IMPACT- THE DISASTERS
ARE GETTING BIGGER NOT SMALLER
YEAH OF ALL THE SEND MAYBE
EVERYONE'S TO ADD TO THIS- I
THINK REALLY THE WHAT WE ONE OF
THE MOST IMPORTANT-
COORDINATING BODIES IN THE CAR
IN A COUNTY- IS THE BOW AT THE
VOLUNTEER ORGANIZATION ACTIVE
IN DISASTER ALL THOSE ENTITIES.
THAT IDEALLY ARE INVOLVED IN A
RESPONSE THAT REALLY SHOULD
KNOW EACH OTHER AND AS EXIT A
GREAT EXAMPLE IN BUTTE THEY
DIDN'T HAVE A BOW OUT SET UP.
AND THESE VOTE ORGANIZATIONS
ARE SO IMPORTANT. WE HAVE
CHARLENE HERE WHO'S. THE
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA OUT OF AT
HI. I JUST WANNA LET YOU KNOW
THAT BEAU ADS OR IN THEIR
SOMETIMES CALLED CO ADDS
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS ACTIVE
IN DISASTERS CAN BE AN
ORGANIZING BODY CAN DO EXACTLY
WHAT YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT SO
THAT. PEOPLE CAN KNOW EACH
OTHER BEFORE THE INCIDENT. THAT
THAT THAT STRUCTURE I THINK IS
A REALLY SOUND ONE- AND IT
MAKES A BIG DIFFERENCE BUT ALL
SEE ABOUT BEING WITH TO ADD.
I'M SURE WELL IT THE VOTE IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT AND
UNFORTUNATELY- SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY HAS HAD LOTS OF
EXPERIENCE WITH DISASTERS
LATELY. SO YOUR VOTE IS QUITE
STRONG HERE AND SO WHEN NON
PROFITS RISE UP OR PEOPLE RISE
UP AND THEY WANT TO PARTICIPATE
IN THIS THEY CAN KIND OF FINAL
THEMSELVES INTO THIS OF- OUT
SYSTEM- BUT- ARE HONESTLY.
DISASTERS ARE SO BIG THAT
THERE'S PLENTY OF ROOM FOR
EVERYONE TO PARTICIPATE. AND SO
WHAT WE TRY TO DO IS THROUGH
OUR DIFFERENT LAYERS OF
CONNECTIONS WITH THE VOEPEL WE
HAVE A REGIONAL BOW OUT AND
THEN WE HAVE OUR- OUR STATEWIDE
THE LAD AND LIKE CURRENT
MISSION WITH CHARLENE HERE. AND
WE TRY TO COORDINATE THAT WE
TRY TO SEE WHAT'S HAPPENING AND
TRY TO HELP AND ASSIST THE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AS THEY DO.
WHAT THEY DO BEST THAT WE
PRACTICE CONSTANTLY AND WE ARE
CONSTANTLY UPDATING OUR PLANS.
AND TRYING TO WORK WITH THE
COMMUNITY- IT'S DIFFICULT
DURING STEADY STATE BUT. WE'LL
DO NOT HAVE- THEY DON'T HAVE TO
GO FAR BACK TO THINK ABOUT WHEN
THE LAST DISASTER WAS. AND SO
THEY'RE OFTEN WILLING TO COME
IN AND SO THAT THAT'S KIND OF
HOW WE COORDINATE BUT- EVERY
DISASTERS DIFFERENT AND SO THEY
ALL. A CHAMPIONS AND LEADERS
WILL RISE OUT OF A DISASTER AND
IT WE GRAB THEM AND PUT THEM TO
WORK. THANK YOU. SEVERAL
QUESTIONS. BALDING AS AS WE
CONTINUE TO TALK. IT IS THE
ADDRESSES IT DOESN'T SOUND LIKE
TO STANDARDIZE PRACTICE. AND I
KNOW THROUGH MY OWN EXPERIENCE-
INVOLVED BUT I STORE MERCED TO
COMMITTEES I REPRESENT A WHICH
IN TWO DIFFERENT COUNTIES WE
ARE WORKING ON HOMELESSNESS AND
TRYING TO THE. THE MOST
CHALLENGING THING I'VE FOUND IS
GETTING ALL OF THE NON PROFITS
THAT WORK IN HOMELESSNESS TO
COORDINATE THE WAY THAT
SUFFICIENT IN A WAY THAT WE'RE
NOT DUPLICATIVE OF WORK AND
RESOURCES AND SO ON IN AN AREA
WHERE WE HAVE LIMITED
RESOURCES. AND IT STRIKES ME.
YOUR THAT IS CERTAINLY THIS
HEARING TODAY BUT ALSO- YOU
KNOW I AS WE CONTINUE TO ROLL
OUT THE CALIFORNIA FOR ALL.
COMMERCIALLY CAMPAIGN. WHAT ARE
THE NEXT STEPS AND WE ESTABLISH
STANDARDS STRUCTURE THROUGH
THAT WHEN IS THAT PROGRAM-
COULD BE EXPANDED TO ALL
COUNTIES. ARE. ONE IS AND HOW
DO WE AUDIT OR OR OR- YOUR BEST
KEEP TRACK OF LESSONS LEARNED.
GOING TO DISASTERS ARE GREAT
QUESTIONS- I KNOW WHEN I WAS
FORMERLY THE CHIEF SERVICE
OFFICER CALIFORNIA VOLUNTEERS
IN CHARGE OF AMERICORPS
VOLUNTEERS AND DONATIONS FOR
DISASTERS ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT SURPRISED ME COMING INTO
THE JOB IS THAT I THOUGHT IT
WOULD BE LIKE A CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE THAT WOULD HAVE
INDUSTRY GROUP INFORMATION
ABOUT LIKE ALL THE NON PROFITS
IN THE HOMELESS ARENA ALL THE
NONPROFIT. DOING TUTORING IN
EDUCATION LIKE THAT THAT WOULD
BE AN ASSET THAT THE STATE MUST
BE TRACKING AND ONLY TO FIND
OUT THERE WAS NO SUCH DOCUMENTS.
AND THERE ARE ASSOCIATION FOR
SOME NONPROFIT KIND OF INDUSTRY
GROUPS FOR LACK OF A BETTER
TERM. BUT BUT THERE ISN'T
ANYTHING THAT I KNOW OF THAT IS
FORMALLY SET UP ACROSS TO ALL
ISSUES. SO YOU'VE GOT THAT KIND
OF COMPLICATION- AND SECONDLY
AS FAR AS THEY'RE THE KIND OF
THE GROWTH EXPANSION OF LEAST
US I MEAN. REACHING A
CONCENTRATE TWENTY FOUR
COUNTIES. WILL BE ARE ARE KIND
OF. WHAT I HOPE WILL BE PHASE
ONE. WE LOOK AT THOSE RESULTS
RIGHT WE SEE THE STRATEGIES
THAT WE TRY AND THEY ARE ALL
BEING CAPTURED IN REPORTS- AND
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL- WE ARE
HOPING TO COME BACK TO THIS
COMMITTEE AND BE ABLE TO GIVE
YOU UPDATES ON. OUR OUR
PROGRESS AND MY HOPE IS THAT IF
IT DOES PROVE TO BE AS
EFFECTIVE IN THIS KIND OF I
THINK NATION LEADING OF A
PRACTICE AS I THINK IT IS. I AM
CONFIDENT THAT THE LEGISLATURE
WILL LOVE TO EXPAND IT- BUT I
THINK WE DO NEED TO WAIT AND
SEE HOW IT GOES. DO YOU THINK
THE. AN AUDIT LIKE A STATE
AUDIT AUDIT TO GOING TO LOOK AT
BEST PRACTICES WOULD BE USEFUL.
WELL I IF YOU'RE ASKING ABOUT
SPECIFICALLY PREPAREDNESS. BEST
PRACTICES OR I CAN I CAN LET
YOU KNOW AS PART OF THE LEASES
CALIFORNIA PROJECT WE'RE DOING
A FULL BLOWN INVENTORY IT'S
LIKE AN AUDIT OF ALL OF THE
PREPAREDNESS CAMPAIGNS BOTH
FEDERAL STATE LOCAL. I'M AND
THOSE THAT ARE GEARED TOWARD
WILD FIRE EARTHQUAKE AND FLOOD
SAID IT CAN INFORM THE
CURRICULUM THAT WE'RE GETTING
OUT THERE. BUT AS FAR AS A AS A
KIND OF AN AUDIT IF YOU'RE
REFERRING MORE TO THE
POPULATIONS IN THE NONPROFIT. I
WASN'T SURE WHAT YOU WERE
REFERRING MORE TO I WAS
SPECIFIC FOR TO THE- OFFERING A
AUDIT LETTER TO THE LEGISLATURE
TO CHURCH OR OTHERS ABOUT IT.
STATE AUDITOR WHICH OFTENTIMES.
I FIND AGENCIES- LOOK AT THE
STATE OUR OFFICES CAN OF A
PUNITIVE ACTION. RIGHT WHEN IN
FACT MY VIEW THE SAY OURSELVES
I USED TO CHAIR THE COMMITTEE
IS THAT WE HAVE THE IMMENSE
ASSET IN THE STATE AUDITOR AND-
ALL THE EMPLOYEES OVER THERE
AND THEY LOOK AT. PROGRAMS AND
OF COURSE THEY ACROSS DIFFERENT
AGENCIES I AM A COME BACK WITH
JUST TREMENDOUS COMMENDATIONS
TO THE LEGISLATURE IT'S A TOOL
I THINK WE OUGHT TO USE A LOT
MORE. MONIQUE AND I AND OUR
COLLEAGUES- BUT I JUST CURIOUS
IF THAT SOMETHING LIKE THAT
BECAUSE IT'S HARD TO DO AN
INTERNAL AUDIT. RIGHT WHAT YOU
CAN DO YOUR PROGRAMS BUT IT'S
HARD TO SOMETIMES GET AFTER THE
RECOMMENDATIONS I THINK MY
FAVORITE. OF IDEA THE WILL THE
ONE THING I TO SPEAK TO IS THAT
THERE'S- COUNTLESS STATE
AGENCIES ALL THAT HAVE
PARTNERSHIPS. WITH THE
NONPROFIT COMMUNITY RIGHT-
DIFFERENT GRANT PROGRAMS SO IF
THERE WOULD BE A WAY TO KIND OF
CONSOLIDATE ALL THAT
INFORMATION ABOUT THE IDEA I
THINK THAT WOULD. BE REALLY
INTERESTING. AN INTERESTING
IDEA. SO I ALSO DID WANT TO ADD
THAT THERE THERE'S WHEN YOU
TALK ABOUT AN ORGANIZATIONAL
MECHANISM. THERE'S PREPARED AND
THEN THERE'S RESPONSE. FOR
EXAMPLE THE RED CROSS WE DEMO
YOU WITH CALORIE YES AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL SERVICES
THAT OUTLINES WHAT WE ARE GOING
TO DO IN CASE OF A DISASTER.
NOT ONLY UNFUNDED BY THE WAY
NOT ONLY THAT BUT- WE ALSO HAVE
EIGHT THE TASK FORCE STRUCTURE
THAT I WAS TALKING ABOUT AT THE
STATE THAT EXISTS I CAN'T AT
THE COUNTY EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT
LEVEL SO THAT IS A REPEATABLE.
ORGANIZATIONAL STRUCTURE PRETTY
ESTHER RESPONSE AND THAT WE'RE
REAPING THAT'S SUPPOSED TO BE
ORDINATING AT ENTITY WITH I'M
BETTER AT IT IF THEY THERE
THERE'VE BEEN SOME HICCUPS
ALONG THE WAY. BUT THAT STRONG
COUNTY EMERGENCY MA'AM.
DISASTERS ALWAYS START LOCALLY.
IF THE IF THEY FOLLOW THE
STRUCTURE THAT SET. THEY'LL
HAVE A BLACK REPRESENTATIVE THE
HAVE A RED CROSS REPRESENTATIVE
THEY'LL HAVE ALL OF THE
AGENCIES IN THE EMERGENCY
OPERATIONS CENTER AND THAT IS
THE KEY TO COORDINATING THE
DISASTER RESPONSE. YEAH I
COMPLETELY HERE YOU'RE SAYING
AT A FOR OUR ORGANIZATION WE'VE
BEEN AUDITED SOMETHING LIKE
FIFTY OR SIXTY TIMES IN THE
PAST FIVE YEARS WHEN YOU'RE
DEALING WITH MEDICINE IT'S JUST
UNBELIEVABLE. BUT FOR THE
PURPOSE OF THE AUDIT IS IMPUTED
VÀ NATURE'S MUCH AS IT'S TO
DEMONSTRATE THE BEST MODELS
THAT EXIST IN WHERE TO SORT OF
POINT YOURSELF. I TRY TO A FIRE
TO BE HAVE A GOAT'S WANTING MY
WE FOCUS REALLY HEAVILY ON
COMPLIANCE BUT I THINK RELATED
TO THAT THESE CONCEPTS AND WHAT
DID YOU JUST TOUCHED ON I THINK
WHAT ALBEIT AT THE STATE LEVEL
WITH THE BUSINESS OPERATIONS
CENTER AT THE TIME TO BE THAT
PUBLIC PRIVATE WORKING GROUP SO
THAT YOU'VE IDENTIFIED READ.
ASSET AND ROLES AS AN EMERGENCY
SO THEN YOU HAVE SOME CLARITY
DURING AN EVENT WHO'S DOING
WHAT WHAT ARE THE CAPABILITIES
WHO CAN YOU RELY ON HOW YOU
ACCESS THINGS YOU MAY NOT EVER
HAVE THOUGHT YOU NEEDED. AND
THAT STRUCTURE PROVIDES THAT
AND THEN I KNOW HERE LOCALLY
WITH ARE AWARE PREPARE
INITIATIVE WE REALLY FOCUSED ON
THAT AS WELL TRYING TO BREAK-
BRIDGE THOSE- PARTNERSHIPS
BETWEEN CITY OFFICIALS COUNTY
OFFICIALS AND THEN THE LOCAL
NONPROFITS THROUGH BOW OUT OR
OR OTHER MEANS- AND THEN I
THINK LASTLY IT'S ENSURING FROM
OUR STANDPOINT IS A NONPROFIT
AND I THINK IT. OTHER
NONPROFITS HERE TRYING TO BE
VERY GOOD AT WHAT YOU'RE DOING
ON A DAY TO DAY BASIS SO THAT
WHEN AN EMERGENCY HAPPENS YOU
ARE NOT TRYING TO RECREATE WE
ALL YOU'RE NOT TRYING TO DO
THINGS YOU'VE NEVER DONE
BEFORE. YOU HAVE ASSISTING
RELATIONSHIPS NOT THINK COMP
NOTE COMBINATION OF THOSE
FACTORS ARE GONNA HELP- PROMOTE
MORE. EFFICIENCY AND GREATER
ACTIVITY IN RELIEF EFFORTS. I
HAVE A FOLLOW UP QUESTION IN IN
THIS PRESENTATION WE HEARD
ABOUT TWO ISSUES THAT I THINK
EVERY SINGLE COMMUNITY IS- IN
CALIFORNIA. IS GRAPPLING WITH
ONE IS- THE NEED FOR MORE
MENTAL HEALTH. SERVICES AND- IN
GENERAL THE PARTICULAR ANY TIME
OF THE DISASTER RESPONSE. AND
THE SECOND ONE IS HOUSING. AT
CAN YOU SPEAK A LITTLE BIT MORE
TO DO. WHAT YOU'RE SEEN AND
WHAT YOU THINK YOU MIGHT WANT
TO SEE IN THE FUTURE IN TERMS
OF NONPROFITS COORDINATING WITH
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES OR MAYBE
NOT QUITE MEETING BUT HAVING
DISCUSSIONS. ABOUT THESE TWO
ISSUES I KNOW THAT. IN THE
LEGISLATURE THOSE ARE NOT
LITTLE ISSUES THOSE ARE REALLY
BIG ISSUES THAT. EVERY COUNTY
GRAPPLING WITH IN IN A IN A
VERY DIFFICULT WAY. SURE I CAN
SPEAK VERY BROADLY ABOUT THAT
BECAUSE THOSE ARE TWO VERY VERY
BIG ISSUES OF MENTAL HEALTH IS
VERY IMPORTANT TO ME PERSONALLY
I HAVE A MENTAL ANXIETY AND SO
THEREFORE I SEE THE NEED AND I
CAN'T EVEN IMAGINE SOME OF THE
TRAUMA THAT PEOPLE EXPERIENCE
DURING THESE DISASTERS AND SO I
AM WORKING WITH OUR- HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES SECRETARY THE
NEW SECRETARY ON FORMING SOME
KIND OF A TASK FORCE FOR CRISIS
COUNSELING. AND BRING PRIVATE
SECTOR BECAUSE THE PRIVATE
SECTOR YOU KNOW THERE'S ALL
THESE TELEHEALTH THERE'S ALL
THE DOCTORS OUT THERE EVERYBODY
WANTS TO GIVE BACK BUT SOMEBODY
HAS TO COORDINATE THAT FROM THE
STATE LEVEL AND THEN WE HAVE TO
BRING IN THE NON PROFITS THAT
ARE IN THE COMMUNITY WORKING ON
IT AND SO THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE ARE WORKING ON
WITH YOU HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES. TO BRING THAT
TOGETHER BECAUSE IT IS A IT
IT'S NOT GETTING ANY BETTER
JUST THE RIDGE CREST EARTHQUAKE
THOSE PEOPLE WITH THE HUNDREDS
OF THOUSANDS OF TROOPS
CONSTANTLY AFTERWARDS. OF. WE
HAD TO TRY TO DO SOMETHING AND
SO THAT THAT'S SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE WORKING ON BUT- AS YOU
KNOW AS AS EVERYONE KNOWS
MENTAL HEALTH HAS. A LONG WAY
TO GO AND- THERE'S A STIGMA
RELATED TO IT WE'RE TRYING TO
BREAK THAT DOWN BECAUSE IT'S
OKAY. TO WANT TO TALK TO
SOMEBODY AFTER YOU'VE BEEN
THROUGH A HORRENDOUS OF IT LIKE
THAT. A REGARDING THE HOUSING I
KNOW THE GOVERNOR NEWSOME HAS
A- MASSIVE PLAN AND IT'S
THROUGH THE BUSINESS CONSUMER
SERVICES AND HOUSING. AND SO I
AM NOT QUALIFIED TO TALK ABOUT
THAT BUT I DO KNOW IT IS
HAPPENING SO. THE ONLY THING
I'LL CHIME IN ON- HELP- SOME
REAL ESTATE INSPIRING MODEL.
TURNING TO ROLL OUT LIKE KAISER
PERMANENT DAYS WORK FOR
CATHOLIC CHARITIES TO EIGHT I'M
A MENTAL HEALTH FIRST AID. THAT
YOU CAN BE TRAINED IN. AND THIS
IS A SPECIAL I THINK IMPORTANT
FOR THOSE IN THE NONPROFIT
FIELD. THAT OFTEN FIND
THEMSELVES IN THE FRONT LINE OF
WORK. PEOPLE THAT HAVE THE
STRUGGLES AND THEY THEMSELVES
DON'T REALIZE HOW THE TWO MAY
BE DEVELOPING. DIFFERENT ISSUE
IS. THERE IN THIS VERY INTENSE
ENVIRONMENT. AND. SO I THINK
THERE'S EXCITING MODELS LIKE
THAT OUT THERE AS WELL. AND
I'LL ADD ON TO THAT WHAT
WORRIES. ME IS WITH THIS EVERY
YEAR THESE LARGE FIRE THESE.
DISASTERS IS THAT THIS IS
SIMILAR TO. WHAT YOU KNOW WE
STRUGGLE WITH THIS AND THE RED
CROSS ARE RESPOND OR IS. THE
ONES THAT RESPONDED TO THE
CAMPFIRE SOME OF THEM IT
RESPONDED SANTA ROSA THE YEAR
BEFORE- I DID YOU SEE YOU TODAY
THAT THERE'S A DOCUMENTARY
COMING OUT ON NETFLIX AND I
WATCHED. THE PREVIEW FOR. FIRE
AND THEY PUT ME RIGHT BACK
THERE AND I DO THIS FOR A
LIVING- WE NEED TO WE NEED TO
ALL WORK TOGETHER AND TAKE CARE
OF EVERYBODY INVOLVED IN A
RESPONSIBLE WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
SEE IS THE NEXT TIME THE SKY
TURNS DARK. THE NEXT TIME IT
FEELS FULL OF SMOKE THERE IS
WIDESPREAD ANXIETY- AND THAT'S
GOING TO BE THE REALITY GOING
FORWARD AND SO ANY KIND OF
PROGRAMS THAT WE CAN PUT
TOGETHER. BOB HI MATT I THINK
WILL MAKE ALL OF OUR RESPONSES
STRONGER. YEAH I JUST ADD THAT-
IN IN A LOT OF OUR DOMESTIC
RELIEF OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS
I THINK AGAIN WE RESPONDED TO.
OUR EVENTS IN THE PAST TWO
YEARS AND PROBABLY THE PAST TEN
COMBINED- AND THE GROWING NEEDS
ASSOCIATED WITH MENTAL HEALTH I
THINK THAT WHAT WE'VE SEEN A
LOT OF MOVEMENT TOWARDS IS A
RECOGNITION OF THE- THE LONG
TERM EFFECTS OF- MENTAL HEALTH.
AND ACTUALLY HOW THAT CAN
AFFECT EVEN CHRONIC DISEASE-
AND THERE'S A LOT OF RESEARCH
OF THIS COME OUT- THAT IS OLD
RESEARCH BUT I THINK IT'S BEING
REVISITED- RELATED TO TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE. AS AS A MODEL IN
PARTICULAR- THERE'S A LOT OF
WORK DONE AND THE ACES SPACE
REGARDING. EVER ADVERSE
CHILDHOOD EVENT AND HOW THOSE A
FACT- HEALTH- RELATED TO TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE- THEY SAY AFTER
WITNESSING- SOMEBODY PASSED
AWAY ONE OF THE MOST- SECOND-
MOST IMPACTFUL THINGS THAT-
HAPPENED INDIVIDUALS IS- FOR-
TRAUMA IS RELATED TO BEING. A
PART OF OUR IN AN EMERGENCY
WHERE YOU FEEL LIKE YOU HAVE NO
CONTROL- WE'VE SEEN A BIG
MOVEMENT IN PORTER RICO TEXAS
AND THEN HERE IN CALIFORNIA. IN
SHASTA IN SANTA ROSA AND-
DEVELOPING TRAUMA INFORMED CARE
PROGRAMS- IN FACT SOME OF THE
HEALTH CENTERS THAT WERE
WORKING WITH IN THE STATE OF
TEXAS. TAKING IT SO FAR AS
WHERE THEY'RE LOBBING THEIR
STATE LEGISLATURE TO SEE IF
THEY CAN GET COVERAGE. FOR
BILLABLE VISITS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE PROVISION OF TRAUMA
INFORMED CARE- THERE SOME GREAT
WORK BEING DONE HERE LOCALLY I
KNOW. AS WELL I THINK. MOVEMENT
AROUND FROM INFORMED CARE IN
TRYING TO ADDRESS SOME OF THE
MENTAL HEALTH. A LOT OF SUCCESS.
I APPRECIATE THAT AND I WILL
NOTE THAT WE DON'T HAVE A LOT
ON HOUSING AND SO THAT WAS THAT
PIECE THAT WILL NEED TO
CONTINUE TO DISCUSS. THE DRILL
DOWN FOR A MINUTE ON THE. BOTH
THE BILL ITSELF FIRST I'M I'M
KIND OF CURIOUS WHAT AMERICANS
WE HAVE IN PLACE TO CASPER YES-
IN ADVANCE OF. THIS DISASTER IS
THE AND THEN SECOND YOU QUEUE
YOU REFERRED TO THE- VOLUNTARY
ORGANIZATIONS- IN ASSISTING IN
DISASTERS OF ADDS. WHAT EXISTS
TO ENCOURAGE PARTICIPATION. IN
LAWS FOR EXAMPLE YOU KNOW WHAT
WHEN WE ISSUE- GRANT FUNDING
THIS IS NOT A REQUIREMENT.
THESE ORGANIZATIONS REFINING
PARTICIPATE IN THESE.
COORDINATED RELIEF ACTIVITIES.
I'M CERTAIN YOU GO WHERE YOU GO.
I DO A LITTLE ROOM I WAS
PREPARING TO ANSWER THE FIRST
QUESTION AND THEN YOU SAID THE
SECOND QUESTION AND I. TOTALLY
LOST THE FIRST QUESTION. SO WE
COULD REPEAT THE FIRST WHICH IS
THE EXTENT TO WHICH WE CAST OUR
PREPARE US TESTER PROGRESS YES
YES- WE DO HAVE EXERCISES WE
ARE CONSTANTLY PRACTICING-
THROUGH OUR EMERGENCY SERVICES
BEYOND THE LOCAL LEVEL. AT THE
STATE LEVEL WE HAVE A MASSIVE
EXERCISE THAT ATTACH TO THE
DIFFERENT FLEET WEEKS OF AND WE
TRY TO PRACTICE WHAT WE PREACH
WHEN IT COMES IN AND WE ALWAYS
TRY TO BRING IN OUR NONPROFIT
PARTNERS TO PRACTICE WITH US.
SOMETIMES IT'S NOT ALWAYS THE
EASIEST BECAUSE THEY HAVE DAY
JOBS THEY HAVE TO KEEP THE
ORGANIZATION RUNNING AND MANY
OF THEM ARE ON LIKE A SHOE
STRING BUDGET AS IT IS. AND SO
BEING ABLE TO STEP OUT OF THAT
TO PRACTICE THE PREPAREDNESS
BUT WE DO ENCOURAGE IT AND WE
TRY TO MAKE IT AS EASY AS
POSSIBLE FOR THEM. A REGARDING
THE VO ADS AT THE MOMENT
THERE'S NOT THAT MUCH WE ARE
LOOKING AT DIFFERENT
ORGANIZATIONS IN DIFFERENT WAYS
OF SUPPORTING THEM. OUT IT'S A
FINE LINE AND I'VE HAD MANY
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE VOTE
WHETHER LEADERSHIP IN
CALIFORNIA ABOUT IT AS TO HOW
MUCH INPUT FROM THE STATE DO
THEY ACTUALLY WANT- BECAUSE- WE
LIKE TO KEEP THEM SEPARATE
THEY'RE THEY'RE THEY'RE
NONPROFIT THEY DON'T WANT US
TELLING THEM WHAT TO DO ALL THE
TIME THEY THEY- DO WHAT THEY DO
BEST- AND SO. BUT AT THE SAME
TIME IS THERE A WAY THAT WE CAN
HELP THEM BUILD UP THAT SUPPORT
AND SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'RE WORKING ON. IS AT THE
STATEWIDE LEVEL HAVING-
NONPROFITS BE INJECTED WITH
EITHER CASH OR SUPPORT SERVICES
FROM THE PRIVATE SECTOR AND
MAKING THOSE CONNECTIONS FOR
THEM. AND SO IT'S- SOMETHING
THAT WE ARE DEFINITELY WORKING
ON- AS THE NEW ADMINISTRATION
IS COMING IN. AND TRYING TO
BUILD THAT UP BUT- AS I'M SURE
YOU'RE VERY AWARE. CALIFORNIA
IS VERY DIFFERENT AND VERY
DIVERSE ALL FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES ARE VERY INDIVIDUAL
THEY HAVE A INDIVIDUAL. NEEDS
AND THEY HAVE INDIVIDUAL
RESOURCES. AND SO BRINGING THEM
ALL TOGETHER. IT'S A HERCULEAN
TASK JUST TO BRING NORTHERN AND
SOUTHERN TOGETHER TRYING TO
BRING. ALL FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
TOGETHER AND HAVE SOMETHING
STANDARDIZED ACROSS THE BOARD.
IT IS NOT THE EASIEST THING BUT
WE ARE WORKING ON IT. AND I'M
TRYING TO ASSIST THEM IN ANY
WAY THAT I CAN. ALL THE STAFF
THAT WORK WITHOUT. SUPPORT
DOLLARS VO ADDS AS AN
INDEPENDENT NONPROFIT- ARE KIND
OF LEFT TO THEIR- OWN YOU KNOW
BUDGETS AND THEIR OWN BAND
WITH. TO BE ABLE TO GATHER
THEIR PEERS TOGETHER. OF FOR
WHAT WE KNOW IS A REALLY
IMPORTANT COORDINATING BODY.
BUT BUT IT'S NOT AS IF THEY
HAVE A BUDGET FOR THAT UNLESS
THEIR LOCAL COMMUNITY HAS
PROVIDED IT IT'S NOT- A STREAM
OF FINE SAID HELLO YES. HOUSE.
CURRENTLY SO I'M JUST I'M JUST
LETTING YOU KNOW THAT- AS I
UNDERSTAND IT WE HAVE SIXTEEN
VO ADS OUT OF FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTIES AND- WE CERTAINLY HAVE
A LOT OF DISASTERS. IN THE VAUD
ADDS STRONG IN ALL OF OUR
COUNTIES. OKAY AT THIS TIME OR
DO SOME A LITTLE DIFFERENT THAN
NORMAL PRACTICE WE DON'T HAVE.
A LOT OF OUR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
HERE ARE FROM MY COMMITTEE OR
MODE SELECT COMMITTEE- SORT
OPEN UP TAKE A FEW QUESTIONS
FROM. THE FOLKS IN ATTENDANCE
AND HOPEFULLY THAT'LL ALLOW
SOME OF YOU TO POTENTIALLY GET.
ARE THE PANEL- HAVING SAID THAT
WE'VE GONE THROUGH ONE HOUR OF
OUR TWO HOURS THAT WE HAVE THIS
ROOM. SO WILL MAYBE TAKE.
SOMEWHERE BETWEEN THREE TO FIVE
QUESTIONS THE MOVE ON TO THE
NEXT PANEL AND REPEAT THAT.
GOOD MORNING CATHY MARIE MAYOR
OF SANTA BARBARA. WELCOME
EVERYONE. FOR HER MY QUESTION
IS ABOUT. AND ELECTRICITY- I'M
ON THE AIR POLLUTION CONTROL
DISTRICT BOARD OF DIRECTORS
HERE IN SANTA BARBARA AND THE
EQUIPMENT TO MEASURE POLLUTE IN
AND FOR AWHILE A SMOKE FROM
WILDFIRES DEPENDS ON POWER. SO
I JUST WANTED TO KNOW. YOUR
THOUGHTS ON LOSS OF POWER I
MEAN DURING AN EMERGENCY WILL
LOSE ELECTRICITY SO MAYBE WERE
PREPARED ON SOME LEVEL BUT
THERE'S THIS NEW- PS PS FROM
THE- UTILITY COMPANIES. IF YOU
HAVE ANYTHING TO SAY ABOUT THAT
BUT I THINK WE'RE ALL TRYING TO
FIND SOME LEVEL OF COMFORT AND
SECURITY ON THAT SUBJECT THANK
YOU. TAG. LIKE TO LOOK AT IT
MAY. SAYS SO ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT WE DO AND WE DO IT IN
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE STATE
AFTER A DISASTER IF THERE IS A
WHOLE EMERGENCY SUPPORT
FUNCTION WHICH IS HOW WE SET IT
UP AROUND POWER AND SO FOR
SHELTERING OR THINGS LIKE THAT
THAT WE DO DO WE GET GENERATORS
WE TRYING TO FIND PLACES THAT
ALREADY HAVE GENERATORS IN
ADVANCE SO WE CAN SURE THAT THE
SHELTER HAS. A GENERATOR- MY
RULE OF THUMB IS THAT THE
SHELTER MEANS POWER IT
DEFINITELY NEEDS TOILETS- AND
SO YOU KNOW THERE IS A THERE IS
A STATE WIDE PLAN FOR AFTER A
DISASTER- AS- AN AND WE CAN.
USE THAT ENTITY AMERICORPS
NATION THAT'S WHERE THE FEMALE
LEVEL COMES IN AND GETS
ESCALATED TO TRY AND HELP
SOURCE THOSE GENERATORS THE.
BILL FOR A DISASTER I'M GOING
TO TURN TO YOU GUYS. HOW DO I
DANCE MOVES OUT OF. THE PUBLIC
SAFETY POWERSHOT ALL SIR A HUGE
ISSUE RIGHT NOW IN CALIFORNIA
OPEN ON THE STATE- SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HAS MORE PRACTICE AT
AT THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
P. JEANNIE IN FACT WERE
ACTIVATED RIGHT NOW HOURS
OPERATIONS CENTER BECAUSE OF A-
PUBLIC SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF
THAT IS HAPPENING. TONIGHT AT
SUNSET I BELIEVE- AND THEN
TOMORROW AND FRIDAY OR THE
WORST DAYS FOR THE RED FLAG AND
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
CUSTOMERS WHICH TRANSLATES TO
ABOUT A MILLION CALIFORNIANS
ARE GOING TO BE AFFECTED- IT IS
NOT SOMETHING THAT WE- ARE.
VERY WELL PREPARED FOR AND
WE'RE CONSTANTLY PUSHING AND
TRYING TO GET MORE INFORMATION.
GOING ON WITH THE UTILITIES.
TRYING TO HAVE THEM BE MORE US
SURGICAL LIKE WITH HOW THEY'RE
DOING IT THAT THE NEED IS
DEFINITELY THAT THERE WE WE'VE
SEEN THAT. BUT HOW THEY'VE BEEN
DOING IT HAS NOT BEEN- UP TO
OUR FOR GOVERNOR NEWSOME. AND
HOW THE ADMINISTRATION WANTS TO
HANDLE IT AND SO. ALL I CAN
TELL YOU IS THAT WE ARE TRYING
TO PUSH AND PUSH AND PUSH AND
WE ARE CONSTANTLY AT THE READY.
TO TRY TO DO THAT- MY JOB
DURING THAT DURING THOSE KIND
OF EVENTS IS TO DEAL WITH THE
BUSINESS ASPECT OF IT BECAUSE
SMALL BUSINESSES. YOU KNOW YOU
LOSE YOUR REFRIGERATION FOR
FIVE DAYS. THERE GOES YOUR
WHOLE THING AND WHAT ARE YOU
GOING TO DO WITH THAT I WAS ON
THE PHONE YESTERDAY WITH UNION
PACIFIC BECAUSE THEY'RE.
SIGNALING RUN ON ELECTRICITY
AND THEY WEREN'T GETTING
INFORMATION FROM THE UTILITIES
AS TO WHERE THEY SHOULD PUT THE
GENERATORS. I MEAN IT WAS JUST.
UP CONSTANTLY TRYING TO GET
MORE AND MORE INFORMATION AND
WE ARE MAKING HEADWAY- BUT IT'S
STILL WE STILL HAVE A WAYS TO
GO SO WE'RE STILL WORKING ON IT.
YEAH I WOULD JUST ADD I THINK
IT'S A IT'S A CRITICAL ISSUE
AND I THINK A LOT OF IT OF
COURSE YOU CAN'T TALK ABOUT I
THINK- POWER OUTAGES OUT TALK
ABOUT SOLAR IN SOME CAPACITY
AND I THINK WHAT'S- THE- PUBLIC
PERCEPTION IS. A SHIFT WHERE IT
LOOKED AT HELLO WHAT IS THE
LONG TERM SORT OF INVESTMENT IN
RETURN ON SOLAR NOW IT'S MORE
OF AN EMERGENCY NEED TO HOW DO
I STAY. ACTIVE AND- OPENED
DURING AN EVENT- WE PUT THOSE
RESOURCES IN AT OUR FACILITY IN
ENSURING NOT JUST SOLAR BUT
ALSO THE BACKUP BATTERIES AS
WELL. ABBIE ALLUDED TO
REFRIGERATION THAT'S A BIG
ISSUE FOR US FOR PEOPLE WHO
NEED ACCESS TO INSULIN'S AND
VACCINES IF WE SHIP STUFF AND
THEN IT GOES TO A- GREATER NAY
LOSE POWER- WITH THIS SURVEY
RECENTLY AND FOUND ABOUT HALF
OF THE- CLINICS CALIFORNIA THAT
WE WERE SUPPORTING HAD NO.
ALTERNATIVE BACKUP POWER
SOURCES TO WE'VE BEEN ACTUALLY
INVESTING MORE IN THAT AREA- MY
COLLEAGUE WHO'S HERE WHO HIT
OVERSEEN OLIVER. IMPORTER GO
ALL OF THE HEALTH PROVIDERS
IMPORTER I HAVE JUST RADICALLY
RETHOUGHT THE PROVISION OF
HEALTH WITHOUT THINKING ABOUT
POWER RIGHT AND THAT THIRD NO
THEY- GET HIT WITH POWER
OUTAGES AGAIN. SO WE'VE DONE
SOLAR AND- FOR ALL OF THE
HEALTH CLINICS. IMPORTER RICO
AND I THINK ARE TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND HOW TO READ.
ACTIVITY LOCAL. ABOUT SOLAR AN
ASSOCIATE A BACKUP BATTERIES I
THINK IN IT AND WE'RE ALSO NOW
STARTING TO STOCK WORKABLE
BATTER- THAT OUR SOUL IS NOT
JUST GENERATORS BUT BATTERIES
CAN BE CHARGED VIA SOLAR AND
DEPLOYED OUT OF WE WERE CLOSE
TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT
FOR FOLKS WHO HAVE COPD OR.
MACHINE THAT NEED AT. A POWER
SOURCE SO IT'S DEFINITELY AN
INVESTMENT THAT WE'RE MAKING
AND AGAIN I THINK IT'S JUST
CHANGING THE WAY WE'RE THINKING
ABOUT SOLAR IS THIS LONG.
INVESTMENT THAT IS GOING TO PAY
OFF SOME RETURN TO NOW THE
NEEDED INVESTMENT BECAUSE AS P.
JEANNIE STATED THE CO I THINK
IT'S- TEN YEARS- THEY HE
ESTIMATED THAT. CALIFORNIA WILL
BE IN THIS P. S. P. S. MODE IS
WE TRY TO SOURCE OUT AT HOW TO
DEAL WITH THE ASSOCIATED- WINS
AND THEN FIRES AND THE POWER.
LÀ WITH IT. QUESTION HERE. MY
NAME IS SHERRIN BURN AND I'M
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF THE
MUNCIE TO ASSOCIATION AND WE
WENT THROUGH THE- THIS WEEKEND
WITH THE P. S. P. S. RIGHT SO.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON A SOLAR
POWERED MICRO GREAT FOR THE
LAST YEAR FOR ALL OF A SUDDEN
WE GOT A WHOLE LOT OF INTEREST.
IN FINISHING THAT OUT RIGHT FOR
THIS VERY REASON. SO ONE OF MY
QUESTIONS I'VE BEEN IN TOUCH
WITH SOME. REALLY MONTHS OFFICE
ABOUT THIS IS YOU KNOW WHAT IS
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA DOING-
THROUGH THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION TO ENABLE MORE
COMMUNITIES TO BE ABLE TO DO
SOLAR POWERED MICRO. A SECOND
QUESTION FOR YET WHICH IS I
ALSO CHAIR OF THE BEHAVIOR ONE
THIS COMMISSION FOR THIS
COUNTY- AND HAVE PARENTS
IMPORTER RICO- THAT WENT
THROUGH HURRICANES IRMA AND
MARIA. IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN-
IT'S WELL KNOWN THE PORTER RICO
AND CUBA HAVE THE BEST TRAUMA
MEDICINE IN THE WORLD. BECAUSE
OF THE FACT THAT THEY GO
THROUGH SO MANY. HURRICANES
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY- BEHAVIOR
WELLNESS HAS HAD TO DO SO. MUCH
MENTAL HEALTH DISASTER
RESPONSE. PREPAREDNESS YOU KNOW
WORKING WITH THE COMMUNITY.
THAT I THINK WE MIGHT BE BEST
IN THE STATE IN TERMS OF. HOW
TO DELIVER THAT MODEL VERY FOR
TO BLEED INTO THE COMMUNITY.
AND I'D LOVE TO SEE IF. YOU
KNOW WE'VE REPORTED ON THIS TO
THE STATE BEHAVIOR WELLNESS-
COMMISSION OVERSIGHT BOARD- I'D
LOVE TO SEE. OTHER COUNTY BE
ABLE LEARN FROM OUR COUNTY ON
HOW TO DO THAT. I'M GONNA JUMP
IN ON- RESPONSE FOR THE STATE
TO I KNOW MY OFFICE IS
CURRENTLY LOOKING AT AT THE
AUDIT WHICH ABOUT ON ITS
EARLIER OF THE CPC- BECAUSE I
THINK ONE OF THE THINGS THAT.
OF ALL SAY IT'S BEEN
MISREPORTED OR PERHAPS NOT
JUST. NOT REPORTED- IN ENOUGH
DETAIL- IS THE FACT THE
PROCEEDINGS CPUC HAVE INVOLVED
INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADES RIGHT.
START POURING THROUGH SOME OF
THE- PREVIOUS- PROPOSALS
THEY'VE BEEN PUT FORTH BY
VARIOUS PARTIES AND FOR EXAMPLE.
THE PLAN TO REPLACE WOULD POLLS.
IS CURRENTLY SET AT TWO HUNDRED
YEARS TO REPLACE ALL THE POLLS
WHICH STRIKES ME AS ODD BECAUSE
WHEN POLLS DON'T LAST TWO
HUNDRED YEARS. AND I SUSPECT WE
START DIGGING A LITTLE DEEPER
WE'RE GONNA FIND A REAL LACK OF
EFFORT- ON PERHAPS- THROUGH CP
HE'S CPU SEES PART. ALSO WE
HAVE TO TAKE SOME
RESPONSIBILITY STATE
LEGISLATURE FOR NOT HOLD THEIR
FEET TO THE FIRE THIS ISSUE
WE'VE CERTAINLY- HELD THEIR
FEET TO THE FIRE ON RENEWABLE
ENERGY. AND WE'VE GONE OUT TO
OUR UTILITIES AND MAKE IT A
PRIORITY IN THE LAST FIFTY
YEARS. MADE GREAT PROGRESS IN
THAT AREA- WE SPENT A LOT OF
MONEY IS A STATE IN THAT AREA
SO IT BEGS THE QUESTION. YOU
KNOW WHY DID WE ARE NOT FINISH
THE INFRASTRUCTURE OR PUSH THE
IN A FLOOD OF STRUCTURE AT
LEAST. PUT IT ON PAR WITH
RENEWABLES AND- TO THE
GOVERNMENT'S POINT OVER HERE
THERE'S OPPORTUNITIES WHERE
THOSE THINGS- WHETHER SOME
CROSSOVER SO I THINK THERE'S A
LOT TO BE DONE I'M GONNA BE
PUSHING THE CPC AT ALL
CERTAINLY. KEEP THE AMOUNTS
OFFICE- NORTH FIVE A WE'RE
DOING PERHAPS SOME WE CAN
PARTNER TOGETHER ON WITH OTHER
MEMBERS LEGISLATORS WILL. NOT
JUST ADDED OVER THE LAST COUPLE
WEEKS ARE- A OUR OFFICES HAVE
BEEN HEARING A LOT FROM
CONSTITUENTS ABOUT THIS- I DO
WANT TO RECOGNIZE THAT TO
ADDISON IS IN THE ROOM TODAY
AND THEY'VE BEEN ENGAGED IN
SOME OF THE CONVERSATIONS. BUT
THERE IS NO DOUBT THAT COME THE
BEGINNING OF THE LETTER. GEN I
IN JANUARY WE'LL SEE MORE
DISCUSSIONS AND PERHAPS POLICY
PROPOSALS- IN TERMS OF WHAT WE
CAN DO- AS A STATE OR LOCAL.
THIS IS ON THE OF THIS IS
UNCHARTERED TERRITORY. AND THE
REASON THAT WE HAVE THE
POWERSHOT UPS WAS WAS DONE TO
PREVENT. MASSIVE FIRES I MEAN
THAT DO THE REASON IS A GOOD
REASON THAT WE WERE WHAT WE
WERE DOING. ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION IS A LEARNING
EXPERIENCE I THINK FOR THE
ENTIRE STATE. AND IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT ONE- AND I KNOW THAT
TO OUR OUR GOVERNOR AND MANY
LEGISLATORS. THE STATE. ARE
ASKING OURSELVES THE HARD
QUESTIONS. WHAT WE CAN DO ABOUT
IT WHERE WE GONNA MAKE THE
FINANCIAL INVESTMENTS WHERE
IT'S- GOING TO COME. VISIT IN A
LOCAL. COMMUNITY COMMUNITY-
WHAT IT CAN BE THE DIFFERENCES
BETWEEN EACH COUNTY AND
COMMUNITIES AND WE GONNA LOOK
THE SAME IN HIGH PROPOSED. HIGH
PROPENSITY- PRONE FIRE AREAS AS
IT WOULD IN OTHER AREAS AND
THOSE ARE THE TYPES OF
QUESTIONS THAT WE NEED TO ASK
OURSELVES. ON THAT I. IMAGINE
WILL BE PART OF AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE STATE OF
PASSION. TO YOUR SECOND POINT.
ABOUT THE MENTAL HEALTH. THIS
WE ACTUALLY- SUZANNE CAN BE
PART OF THAT THE- PANEL. THE
SECOND PANEL SO I'LL JUST.
ALTHOUGH A LOT THEN I TALK A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT THAT.
FOLLOW UP OF IT TOO AND. ADD TO
WHAT I ALREADY SAID IN THAT THE
OPPOSITION TO A LOT OF US
INFRASTRUCTURE UPGRADES WAS
RIGHT ADVOCACY GROUPS RIGHT-
WHEN YOU GO BACK LOOKED
PROCEEDINGS AND ORGANIZATIONS
LIKE UTILITY REFORM NETWORK-
TURN WHICH LOOKS AFTER-
RATEPAYERS INTEREST AND I THINK
THERE'S A LARGER ISSUE AND- ALL
RAISE THIS AND THIS MAY NOT BE
A POPULAR STATEMENT. IN THIS
COMEDIAN THIS CROWD I REPRESENT
CAN INLAND CALIFORNIA I'M
SITTING ON COASTAL CALIFORNIA
BUT- THE REALITY OR UTILITY
RATES HAS BEEN SIGNIFICANT
INCREASES FOR PEOPLE I
REPRESENT BECAUSE WE LIVE IN A
HOT OR COLD CLIMATE RIGHT SO IS
CALIFORNIA'S PURSUED YOUR REAL
LETTER SHE AND ALL OF THE KIND
OF WORTHWHILE GOALS THAT WE SAT
IN MANY CASES AND SHE GREAT
PROGRESS ON. THAT'S COME AT THE
EXPENSE OF SOME OF THE POOREST
PEOPLE IN THE STATE RIGHT IT'S
NOT UNCOMMON TO HAVE A TWO
THREE FOUR FIVE HUNDRED DOLLAR
EACH ANY BILL- AND THEN YOU GO
TO NANCY SCANNERS DISTRICT IN
BERKELEY AND YOU HAVE A FAIRLY
YOU KNOW WEALTHY PEOPLE WITH
EIGHTY DOLLAR BILLS- SO IT'S
NOT BEEN- WITH NOT FOUND A WAY
TO CAN EQUALIZE OUR INVESTMENTS
ACROSS THE STATE FOR A FINANCE
PERSPECTIVE. AND I THINK THAT'S
GOING TO BECOME EVEN MORE
DIFFICULT WE HAD DISCUSSIONS IN
THE GEO CAN BE THIS PAST YEAR.
WHEN THE AREAS MOST. AFFECTED
BY THE WILD FIRES WERE LOOKING
TO. FOR TO HELP THESE ERRORS
BUT I THINK THE ANSWER ALL
THESE QUESTIONS IS THAT WE'RE
ALL GOING TO HAVE TO PITCH IN
TOGETHER IS A STATE. TOWARDS
COMMON GOALS RECOGNIZE EACH OF
OUR REGIONS HAS DIFFERENT
CHALLENGES. AND TRY TO FIND-
YOUR FAIR WAY TO MOVE FORWARD
AND I THINK THAT'S GOING TO
ADDRESS SOME OF THE- THE RATE.
ABBASI OPPOSITION THAT PROBABLY
IS STOOD IN THE WAY OF NEEDED
INVESTMENTS ON INFRASTRUCTURE
SO SORRY FOR THE LONG ANSWER
BUT I THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT
POINT. YOUR FOLLOW UP. AT THIS
POINT WHY DON'T WE MOVE ON TO
THE NEXT PANEL AND THEN WELL
ACTUALLY IT WILL TAKE ONE MORE
QUESTION HERE AND THEN WE'LL
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT PANEL. GOOD
MORNING I'M A SEVENTY RESIDENT
OF SANTA BARBARA. AND THE ONE
THREE THANK YOU TO YOU. OF
COMING HERE. MY DAUGHTER MY SON
IN LAW WERE ALMOST BURNED TO
DEATH IN THE TO FIND. SOME WILL
ACQUAINTED WITH THE SERVICES
AND THE FALCONS WORK- ONE OF
THE THINGS I HEARD ABOUT
HOUSING. WITH ONE TO INTERVIEW
YOU. LOSE A WHOLE HELL.
FORTUNATE FOR THEM THEY WERE
RENTED. BUT IT'S BEEN MY
EXPERIENCE THAT A LOT OF THE
PEOPLE THAT LIVED THERE CAN NO
LONGER LIVE UP THERE BECAUSE
THERE'S TOO MANY REGULATIONS
THEY BOUGHT THE HOME THIRTY
YEARS AGO THE REGULATIONS WERE
DIFFERENT. AND NOW THEY CAN'T
GO BACK. FIVE HUNDRED OF. OUR
FIVE HUNDRED GALLON WATER TANK
AND THEY HAVE TO HAVE THE ROAD
AND SO. IS THERE A WAY TO ALLOW
PEOPLE OR GET SOME ASSISTANCE
FOR THEM TO GO BACK- TO THAT
AREA I KNOW SOME OF THAT AREA.
IS UNINHABITABLE BECAUSE IS
BURNED SO BADLY BUT- I THINK IF
WE HAD THE REGULATIONS WHERE
THEY MIGHT RECEIVE SOME. OUR
SYSTEM OF THE COULD BACK IN THE
BILL. OF THE ONE OF THANK YOU
THIS IS NOT AN EASY TASK IS
LIKE TWENTY NINE CATS IN THE
BACK. OF AND I KNOW THAT THERE
ARE. I WOULDN'T KNOW WHAT TO DO
WITHOUT THE RED CROSS BECAUSE
WELL MY CHILDREN WERE IN THE
ROOM WHERE I COULD GO TO THE
LOCAL RED CROSS AND JUST SIT
THERE. WITH SOMEONE AND THEY
WOULD TALK TO ME AND ASSURE. ME
OF SO WE DO NEED TO THE CUT.
EVEN IF YOU'RE NOT IN THE WAY
YOU DO GET INFECTED SO THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. I AM REALLY GLAD
THE RED CROSS IS THERE FOR YOU-
THAT THAT'S THAT'S PART OF WHAT
WE TRAIN DO THERE YOU KNOW IT I
KEEP USING THE TERM WHOLE
COMMUNITY BUT IT DOES TAKE. A
WHOLE COMMUNITY TO RECOVER FROM
THIS DISASTER THESE TYPES OF
DISASTERS AND THAT INCLUDES THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT. SO YOU KNOW
FROM BREED REMOVAL TO SOME
PAYMENTS TO PEOPLE TO
REBUILDING CODES TO I MEAN. IT
IS ALL DESIGNED TO HELP PUT
PEOPLE IN A BETTER SPACE AND TO
LET THEM RECOVER THE PROBLEM IS
THAT NONE OF IT IS FAST- IN A
REBUILDING PARADISE IS GONNA
TAKE. AND NOBODY EVEN KNOWS HOW
LONG YOU KNOW WHEN YOU'RE HOME
BURNS DOWN COMPLETELY. THE
GROUND IS BASICALLY HAZARDOUS
MATERIAL AND IT'S GOT TO BE DUG
OUT THAT'S THE VERY FIRST STEP
SO. THAT IS PART OF THE
CHALLENGE WITHOUT AND
AVAILABILITY OF HOMES TO RENT
OR PURCHASE EVEN IF YOU GET A
CHECK FROM YOUR INSURANCE
COMPANY YOU KNOW THAT'S KIND OF
THAT STRUGGLE IS WHAT DO WE DO
AND I DON'T KNOW THAT WE HAVE
AN ANSWER I KNOW IT'S
DEFINITELY BEING TALKED ABOUT.
AT AT THE GOVERNMENT LEVEL-
BUT- I BAG I DON'T THINK I HAVE
AN ANSWER. IN EVERY DOESN'T
EITHER LOOKING OUT. THAT I HAVE
AN ANSWER. A ALL THESE THINGS
THAT WE TRY TO THEM AS A CASE
BY CASE BASIS AND- LIKE DENISE
MENTIONED EARLIER ABOUT A
SHELTER TASK FORCE WE ALSO HAVE
A HOUSING TASK FORCE BECAUSE
THIS IS A MASSIVE ISSUE ACROSS
THE BOARD BECAUSE WHEN YOUR
HOUSE BURNS DOWN. AND IT'S
YOU'VE BEEN THERE FOR THIRTY
YEARS LIKE YOU SAID THERE'S ALL
THESE NEW REGULATIONS AND NEW
RULES THAT ARE COMMON TO PLACE
WE CAN'T AUTOMATICALLY WAIVE
THOSE BECAUSE WHAT ABOUT THE
PERSON THAT BOUGHT THAT BUILT
THEIR HOUSE THE DAY BEFORE THE
DISASTER AND THEY DIDN'T BURN
THAT'S NOT REALLY FAIR ALL
THAT. ALL THAT FUN STUFF AND SO
WHAT THEY TRY TO DO IS
INDIVIDUALLY HELP AND WALK
THROUGH AND THEY WORK VERY
CLOSELY OF THE HOUSING TASK
FORCE IS MADE UP OF NOT ONLY
STATE FOLKS BUT ALSO THE BULK
OF IT BEING LOCAL AUTHORITIES.
TO TRY TO UNDERSTAND HOW THEY
CAN ASSIST AND HELP WITH THAT
AND SO THAT THAT'S ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT WE DO IT IS A HUGE.
HUGE G. DAY TO CAL UP IN THAT
CROSS THE BOARD RURAL COASTAL
YOU NAME IT. HOUSING IS AN
ISSUE AND SO I THERE'S A- FORCE
THAT IS WORKING ON THAT AS WE
SPEAK. I'M GONNA JUMP IN AND
TAKE THE BOAT SIR FOR OUR PANEL
ON THAT HOUSING- I DON'T DRIFT
OFF TOO FAR INTO HOUSING IN
THAT THAT'S NOT REALLY WHAT
WE'RE HERE TO TALK ABOUT TODAY-
BUT CERTAINLY DO JUST A PROBLEM
IN PERSPECTIVE BEFORE YOUR NEXT
PANEL. YEAH WE'RE CURRENTLY
BUILDING SOMEWHERE IN THE
NEIGHBORHOOD OF A HUNDRED A
HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND HOMES
PER YEAR STATEWIDE. GOVERNOR
NEWSOME'S TALKING ABOUT TRYING
TO BUILD THREE OR FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND HOMES STATEWIDE. IN
ORDER TO ADDRESS A THREE
MILLION HOME SHORTFALL. IN
SUPPLY. AND I JUST IF YOU'RE
POSITIVE THINK OF THAT IF WE'RE
GONNA GO FROM BUILDING HUNDRED
THOUSAND HOMES TO FOUR HUNDRED
THOUSAND HOMES THAT MEANS WE
NEED FOUR TIMES AS MANY PEOPLE
TO WORK ON BUILDING HOMES AND
WE'VE DONE A FAIRLY INEFFECTIVE
JOB IN LAST THIRTY TO FORTY
YEARS IN CALIFORNIA OF TRAINING
YOUNG PEOPLE TO DO THOSE TYPES
OF JOBS TO BE PLUMBERS
CARPENTERS WRITERS SO. ON THE
UPSIDE WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY
RIGHT TO HAVE A WHOLE
GENERATION OF PEOPLE HAVE GOOD
PAYING JOBS- ON THE DOWNSIDE WE
DON'T HAVE AN EDUCATION SYSTEM
PLACE THIS PREPARING STUDENTS
TO DO THOSE THINGS. SO IT IS A
IT IS A- ALMOST- UNTHINKABLE
SOLUTION ARE IMMEASURABLE-
PROBLEM. FOR CALIFORNIA ADDRESS
WE DO HAVE A GOVERNMENTS COMMIT
DRESS YET I KNOW OUR
COLLEAGUES- WANT TO ADDRESS IT
IT'S A REQUIRE ALL OF US TO GET
OVER A LOT OF THINGS JUST LIKE
OUR PREVIOUS POINT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO THEM THESE ARE GOING TO
HAVE TO. GET OVER THEMSELVES
THE COSTA COMMITTEES ARE GONNA
HAVE TO BUILD HOUSES WE HAVE A
WHOLE BUNCH OF. PEOPLE I'M
HAPPY BUT IF WE ALL PITCH IN
TOGETHER STATEWIDE I THINK WE
CAN. WE CAN ACCOMPLISH THIS SO
WE CAN ACTUALLY- HAVE SOME
ECONOMIC BENEFIT FOR A NOT A
WHOLE GENERATION. WE'RE GONNA
MOVE ON TO THE NEXT PANEL
BECAUSE WE'RE DRIFTING FAR OFF
OF OUR SUBJECT. LET'S LOOK
LET'S GIVE A ROUND OF APPLAUSE
TO THIS PANEL THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TIME. OKAY SO WELCOME OUR
NEW PANEL LET ME WILL GET
STARTED MOMENTARILY. AND WHILE
WE WELCOME THE NEW PANEL I JUST
WANNA RECOGNIZE WE DO HAVE
SANTA BARBARA MAYOR CATHY
MARIE- HERE SUPERVISOR GREG
HART IS HERE AND WE HAVE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM CONGRESS
MEMBER CARVAJAL'S OFFICE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACQUI AT. I'M
SORRY ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHRISTY
SMITH'S OFFICE SENATOR
JACKSON'S OFFICE A SUPERVISOR
APARTMENT IN WILLIAMS AND-
SANTA BARBARA FIGHT
REPRESENTATIVES ARE HERE WHEN
THE SIMS MO AND JACKIE READ.
THANK YOU ALL FOR BEING HERE
.
OKAY WE'RE GONNA BEGIN WITH THE-
ASSISTING BOB IN THE COUNTY
SANTA BARBARA PLEASE PROCEED
WITH YOUR COMMENT. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LIMON FOR HAVING US HERE
TODAY AND- GIVEN US AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HIGHLIGHT SOME
OF OUR SUCCESSFUL PARTNERSHIPS
HERE LOCALLY WITH SOME OF OUR
NON PROFITS. SO I REALLY
APPRECIATE- THE PREVIOUS
PANELS- TERMINOLOGY AS THEY
WENT THROUGH THEIR VARIOUS.
VISITATIONS ESPECIALLY THE
WORDS WHOLE COMMUNITY BECAUSE
THAT'S ALL WE KNOW HERE IN
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY IT IS
FUNDAMENTAL TO OUR X. SIX HERE-
AS FACE- ON PRESIDENT DISASTERS
AND EMERGENCIES. SO I THINK I'M
GONNA KINDA TALK A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE GOVERNMENT
PERSPECTIVE TODAY TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT IT'S- HOW
TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN WORKING
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENT- AND THEN
CUT UP. FOCUS MY TIME ON THE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN THE COUNTY.
BARBARA PARTNERSHIP FOR
RESILIENT COMMUNITIES I SEE A
LOT OF FRIENDS AND COLLEAGUES
OUT IN THAT AUDIENCE HERE TODAY
THAT WE HAVE SUCCESSFUL
RELATIONSHIPS WITH AND I COULD
TALK FOR DAYS ON WHAT WE ALL
THAT- WENT THROUGH AND SOME OF
THE STRONG RELATIONSHIPS AND-
GREAT THINGS THAT WE FOUND. WE
PUT TOGETHER AT AND- AND WERE
SUCCESSFUL OUT HERE LOCALLY BUT
I'M GONNA STICK TODAY WITH THE
PARTNERSHIP RESIGNED
COMMUNITIES. I THINK ONE OF THE
IMPORTANT THINGS AS WE MOVE
THROUGH. I'M PLANNING FOR THE
NEXT DISASTER AS WERE STILL
RECOVERING FROM THE THOMAS FIRE
AND ONE NINE DEBRIS FLOW IS
THAT MAKING SURE THAT EVERYBODY
KNOWS EVERYONE IN OUR
COMMUNITY. KNOWS THAT THEY HAVE
A ROLE- WITH US IN HELPING
COVER AND THAT MEANS BUSINESSES
INDIVIDUALS CHURCHES NONPROFIT
FOR PROFIT ORGANIZATIONS. IN
EVERYONE OF THEIR ROLES ON A
DAY TO DAY BASIS THERE'S A
LITTLE WILL ROOM THERE THERE'S
ROOM TO HELP THERE'S ROOMS TO
FIND WAYS TO SAY YET THERE'S
ROOM. TO PARTNER TOGETHER. AND
THERE'S ALSO A FEELING OF
PERSONAL RESPONSIBILITY FOR ALL
OF US THEY'RE PART OF OUR
COMMUNITIES TO WORK TOGETHER.
AND I KNOW THAT FUNDAMENTALLY
THAT'S WHY THE PARTNERSHIP
RESILIENT COMMUNITIES CAME
TOGETHER. UNITED AND PARTNERED
WITH US. THE THOMAS FIRE NO ONE
NINE DEBRIS FLOW. WE
EXPERIENCED HERE IT WAS AN
UNPRECEDENTED SITUATION CHOIR A
LOT OF COORDINATION WITH OUR
NONPROFIT SECTOR. THERE ARE
THINGS THAT ARE TYPICALLY
THOUGHT OF AS THE GOVERNMENT'S
ROLE ESPECIALLY RESPONDING TO
EMERGENCIES. TO TELL YOU TODAY.
ISN'T THE ONLY PARTNER THAT'S
REALLY NEEDED WHEN A FULL SCALE
EVENT HAPPENS. TO BE SUCCESSFUL
WE HAVE TO HAVE EVERYONE IN OUR
WHOLE COMMUNITY. ALSO DOES NOT
FAMILIAR NAVIGATING PROJECTS
THROUGH THE GOVERNMENT
BUREAUCRACIES. SOMETIMES IT CAN
BE A HUGE CHALLENGE ESPECIALLY
IF YOU'RE JUST TRYING TO HELP.
AND WE'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF AN
EMERGENCY. PLEASE UNDERSTAND
THAT THE GOVERNMENT ARE YOUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND ALL OF OUR
GOVERNMENTS ARE PEOPLE AND
THEIR PEOPLE WORKING HARD. AND
FOLLOWING MANY PEOPLE BEFORE
THEM. IN SERVING THE COMMUNITY
AND- THAT IN IN OUR OPERATION
AND GOVERNMENTAL OPERATIONS
WERE OFTEN TAUGHT. THAT BY THE
TIME YOU ENTER YOUR GOVERNMENT
TO MAKE SURE THAT YOUR WORK IS
ALIGNED WITH YOUR MISSION AND
MAKE SURE THAT- THAT YOU CARRY
OUT YOUR MISSION AND A FAIR AND
ETHICAL WAY. AND THE EASY
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF
POLICIES A LOT OF REGULATIONS
AND SOMETIMES WHEN WE HAVE AN
EMERGENCY IT'S HARD TO THINK
OUTSIDE THE BOX AND RECOGNIZE.
THAT WE NEED ASSISTANCE. SO ONE
OF THE KEY FUNDAMENTAL THINGS
IS MAKING SURE THAT THERE'S
ALIGNMENT. OF A NON PROFIT-
WITH ONE OF OUR MISSIONS AND IN
OUR VARIOUS DEPARTMENTS. AND I
THINK THAT EVERY TIME YOU USE
THE WHOLE COMMUNITY APPROACH
YOU'RE GONNA FIND ALIGNMENT
WITH WHATEVER THE MISSION OF
THAT NONPROFIT OR VOLUNTEER
ORGANIZATION IS. AND I REALLY
BELIEVE THAT. DEBT EMERGENCIES
GIVE US A CHANCE TO TEST NEW
PARTNERSHIPS A CHANCE FOR US
ALL TO THINK DIFFERENTLY AND A
PROBLEM SOLVED DIFFERENTLY. AND
ONE OF THE MOST IMPORTANT PART
OF MY PIECES OF THAT IS FOR US
ON THE GOVERNMENT SIDE TO
LISTEN. MEANS LISTENING. TO
CRITICISMS SOMETIMES MAYBE
THEY'LL COME IN COMMITTEE
MEETINGS OR THROUGH ELECTED
OFFICIALS ARE THROUGH SOCIAL
MEDIA. BUT THOSE CRITICISMS ARE
REALLY WHERE YOU'RE GAPS ARE.
AND A AND THEIR OPPORTUNITIES
FOR. US TO WORK HARDER AND WORK
DIFFERENTLY TO LEVERAGE OUR
NONPROFIT RELATIONSHIPS. TO
HELP FILL THOSE GAPS IN THE
COMMUNITY. AND I KNOW THAT.
DISASTERS START AND END LOCALLY.
AND IT REALLY IS US. WE HAVE
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AT
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT HELPING TO
BACK US TO GET US THOSE
TECHNICAL EXPERTISE AND THE
RESOURCES WE NEED WHEN IT AND
EMERGENCY EXCEEDS OUR ABILITY.
TO RESPOND HERE LOCAL. BUT IT'S
REALLY US IN A COMMUNITY
THEY'RE GONNA BE HERE LONG
AFTER DISASTER TO PULL THINGS
TOGETHER. SO. ONE OF THE FIRST
THINGS WE HAVE TO DO EVEN
BEFORE THE DISASTER IS WORK
TOGETHER AND TO COMMUNICATE
TOGETHER AND THEN WHEN A
DISASTER STRIKES ONE OF THE
THINGS WE NEED TO BE PREPARED
TO DO IS ASK OURSELVES WHO HAS
THAT EXPERTISE IN THIS TYPE OF
DISASTER VISIT US LOCALLY IS
THIS SOMETHING WE REGULARLY
HAVE LIKE A WILDFIRE IS
SOMETHING DIFFERENT AND THAT'S
WHAT ONE NINE PRESENTED US.
WITH A DIFFERENT TYPE OF
EMERGENCY THAT WE NEEDED SOME
SPECIALIZED HELP FOR AND THAT'S
WHERE THE PARTNERSHIP A
RESILIENT COMMUNITIES CAME
TOGETHER AND ASKED THE COUNTY
WHAT DO YOU NEED WOULD BE
HELPFUL TO GET SOMEONE THERE
COULD BE A PROJECT EXPERT FOR
YOU THE COULD COME TOGETHER AND
UNDERSTAND THE CHALLENGES OF
WORKING THROUGH- THE RECOVERY.
AND THE REBUILDING OF MODESTY
TO. AND I THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GROUP BE TALKED EARLIER ABOUT
THE ALIGNMENT OF INDIVIDUAL
GROUPS. AND HOW. HOW THAT
HAPPENS- WE KNOW IN EMERGENCY
SOME GROUPS POP UP ORGANICALLY-
SOME. ARE MORE STRATEGIC AND
I'VE BEEN AROUND FOR A LONG
TIME AND SERVE MANY
COMMUNITIES. SOME OF THEM COME
TOGETHER AND MODIFY THEIR
SCOPES AND BECOME A BIGGER
FORCE FORCE. AND OTHERS-
CONTINUE THE WORK THAT THEY'RE
OUT THERE WERE. DOING ON A DAY
TO DAY BASIS. AND I THINK THEY
IN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY WE
TURNED TO A LOT OF THE SCIENCE
BEHIND DEBRIS FLOWS AND WE
TRIED TO LEARN AS MUCH AS WE
COULD AND WE WERE THE ONLY ONES
DOING THAT THE PARTNERSHIP
REZAEI COMMUNITIES ALSO WAS OUT
THERE HIRING SCIENTISTS TRYING
TO UNDERSTAND WHAT WHAT COULD
HAPPEN AS WE CONTINUALLY LIVED
UNDER ADDITIONAL RISK. WITH
STORMS IN THE FORECAST. AND
THEY DONATED- PROJECT EXPERT TO
HELP US WORK THROUGH SOME OF
THAT CHOREOGRAPHING THE
RESTORING THE WATER POWER GAS
THE ROADS THE BRIDGES THAT WERE
OUT. WHILE YOU'RE MOVING DUMP
TRUCKS FULL OF MUD AND DEBRIS
OUT OF THE COMMUNITY. SO THAT
WAS REALLY IMPORTANT AND THEN
THEY ASK THEMSELVES WHAT ELSE
CAN WE DO WHAT ELSE CAN WE HELP
WITH. MET WITH A LOT OF
VOLUNTEER ORGANIZATIONS AND
THEY CAME UP WITH THE IDEA OF
INSTALLING THE NETS AND WANNA
LET PAT TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE NETS AND WHAT THEIR- GROUP
REALLY WAS TASKED WITH. BUT I
THINK THAT. IN ORDER TO WRAP
UP. IT LEE IS THIS MATCH MAKER
THAT ABIGAIL BROUGHT UP EARLIER
FUNCTION. THAT WILL GET YOU. TO
BE SUCCESSFUL WORKING WITH YOUR
LOCAL GOVERNMENT. IN THIS
PARTICULAR CASE IT TOOK
INDIVIDUALS FROM OUR FLOOD
CONTROL DISTRICT. FROM OUR
LEGAL TEAM. FROM OUR POLICY
MAKERS ARE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS. OUR DEPARTMENT
THAT ACTED AS REGULATORS TO
MAKE SURE THAT OUR OUR METAL
INTERESTS WERE PROTECTED.
DURING THESE. AND A LOT OF.
FOLKS THE PARDON THERE TOGETHER
WITH THE COMMUNITY TO MAKE SURE
THAT THESE WERE SIX UP. SO I
THINK THAT AS AS- I WRAP UP AND
TURN IT OVER TO MY COLLEAGUES
HERE FOR THIS PARTICULAR
PARTNERSHIP. IT REALLY IS THEN
THE- THE ABILITY TO BE FLEXIBLE
THE ABILITY PATIENT. AND THE
ABILITY TO CONTINUE TO WORK
HARD. WITH WITH EACH OTHER. FOR
THE OVERALL GOOD OF THE
COMMUNITY SO. THANK YOU. THANK
YOU MATT THANK YOU FOR INVITING
US HERE TODAY HI MY NAME IS PAT
MCELROY- I WAS A FIRST
RESPONDER FOR THIRTY SEVEN
YEARS IS COUNTY. AND WAS ONE OF
THE PEOPLE THAT WAS MANAGING
THE THOMAS FIRE AND THE DEBRIS
FLOW. AND SO- UPON MY
RETIREMENT I STARTED WORKING
WITH A GROUP THAT WAS FORMED
AFTER THE DEBRIS FLOW NUMBER GO
THROUGH SOME QUICK SLIDES BUT
NOTHING NOTHING. I PROMISED TO
TOO LONG. I BELIEVE IN THE
CLIMATE CHANGES HAPPENING. I'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH IT IN THE OLD
LAST SEVERAL YEARS IN THE FIRE
WORLD. AND WHAT I'M WHAT I'M-
REALIZING THAT IS THAT IT'S NOT
ONLY THAT CLIMATE CHANGE A BIT
MEANS IT. WORK VISAS WERE
HAVING ARE NOT ONLY GETTING
BIGGER THEY'RE BECOMING MORE
FREQUENT. AND THE RESULTS
AFTERWARDS ARE ARE BECOMING
MORE OBVIOUS TO US SO. WHEN I
LOOK AT THESE DISASTERS NOW ONE
OF THE THINGS THAT THAT I THINK
ABOUT IS WHAT WE'VE DONE BEFORE
STILL GOING TO BE A FACTOR BUT
WE HAVE TO LOOK THE PROBLEM
DIFFERENTLY AND I THINK WE LOOK
AT THE PROBLEM- DIFFERENTLY.
BECAUSE WHEN WE'RE WE'RE.
FIGHTING FIRES- I WOULD FROM
THOMAS FIRED MENDOCINO COMPLEX
AFTER RETIRED FOR HELP WITH AN
INVESTIGATION AND I'M GONNA
TYPE ONE TEAM AND WE TOOK OVER
FROM TO TYPE ON TEAMS THAT HAD
FOR THREE WEEKS WE HAD IT FOR
TWO WEEKS AND TURN IT OVER TO
SOMEBODY ELSE. SO THAT'S ONLY
SIX OR SEVEN WE. THAT'S JUST ON
PRESIDENT HAS TO OUR THOUSAND
ACRES BURNED IN THE THOMAS FIRE
BY THE WAY. RIGHT OUT BACK TO
THE DEBRIS FLOW PROJECT WE WERE
A GROUP OF PEOPLE FORM RIGHT
AFTER THE- THE INCIDENT. AND
IT. THE FIRST MET IN THE-
DINING CAR TOSSED THEY WERE
BEING. AND WE. THEY CAME TO ME
EVERYONE SOMETHING AND THEN THE
PEOPLE WITH THE KIND OF THE NEW
SERVER. WE WERE TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT IS. WE HELP WE KNEW
THAT AND WITH THE RESPONDING
AGES TWENTY FLOOD CONTROL FIRST
BOND. THEY HAVE NO ABILITY TO
ADD TO THEIR TAX. SO WE ARE
LOOKING AREA. HE WAS WORKING
AND WE- MORE. YOU'RE GREAT.
OKAY WHAT GROUPS LIKE THAT OR
WHAT WE DIDN'T DO THAT SO WE
WANTED TO CONCENTRATE ON IS THE
AREA ABOVE. BASICALLY MOUNTAIN
DRIVE WHERE THE DEBRIS FLOWS
CAME FROM AND WE WOULD WE KEPT
IT LOOKING AT A COUPLE OF SITES
LIKE THIS IS PART ONE POINT OF
THIS. CANYON AND THIS IS TWO
HUNDRED ALL OF MIL ROUTE WHO
KNOWS THAT THE CHARACTER OF THE
DEBRIS IT IS A- CLOSE. WHAT. ON
A REGULAR BASIS. AND IN THAT
YEAH IN SWITZERLAND AND JAPAN
WE FOUND SOME TO DARGIE WE
STARTED A RAISING SOME MONEY WE
WERE VERY LUCKY EARLY ON HAVE A
COUPLE PEOPLE GIVE US SOME
SIZEABLE DONATION JUST TO GO
OUT FIND WHAT THERE IS OUT
THERE. AND SO MATT SAID WE WENT
TO THE COUNTY COULD. AFTER
SPENDING MY CAREER IN
GOVERNMENT. THE LAST THING I
WANT IS SOME CITIZENS ARE
GOVERNMENT FOR COMING UP AND
TELLING ME HOW TO DO MY JOB. SO
WE ASKED THEM WHERE COULD WHERE
CAN WE HELP WHERE DO YOU NEED
HELP. WOULD IT HELP YOU IF WE
WERE LOOKING UP FOR THESE
CANYONS DURING. MAPPING THE
DURING SEVENTY FIVE- GEO
MAPPING AND THEY SAID YES SO
THAT'S WHAT WE DID. IN THIS
TEAM STARTED. SMALLER GROUP IN
THE WINTER. AS WE MOVED HERE
THERE'S SOME NEWS PART THAT'S
CELEBRATE OUR- FIRE OUR GROUP.
BRING WITH THE COUNTY. AWESOME.
WE WERE VERY CLEAR TURN WE
WOULD BE SUPPORTIVE AND CORRECT
AND I KIND OF WANT BUT HOW
WOULD DEAL WITH OTHER AGENTS WE
WANTED. WITH RESPECT TO LIVE IN
THIS AREA. OUR CONCERNS IMPACT
ON TRAIL. AND WE CON. THREE IT
IS ALSO WITH. THE BRIEF WELL
AND LOOKING YES I WAS. WHAT WE
WANT TO DO. OTHER WEEK. CAN
STOP A REPORT WE BREAK. WE
STOPPED LARGE MATURE. A LOT WAS
A SETTLEMENT WATER TO CONTINUE
THROUGH DO IT SO IT'S TIED UP
ABOVE THE CREEK SO THAT DOESN'T
IMPEDE THE ANIMAL OR FISH
PASSAGE THESE ARE ALL THINGS
THAT WE ENGAGED LARGE GROUPS OF
THE COMMUNITY DIFFERENT-
INTEREST GROUPS ON WHAT THEY'RE
WHAT THEY NEEDED TO SEE FROM AS
WE MADE CHANGES CONTRAILS RATE.
CHANGES BASED ON HABITAT. WE
HAD TO GO THROUGH WHAT WE WANT.
SO ALL THESE THERE. WHICH ARE
NOT BEING MODIFIED- COUNTY
STARTING IN TWENTY STARTING IN
TWENTY TWENTY SO GIVE
PROTECTION WHILE IT ADDS A
PROTECTION WHILE THOSE TO BE
BASES ARE BEING MODIFIED THESE
WITH IT. THESE ARE THE AREAS
THE ANNUAL WE WENT OUT FOR
PERMITS. COLD SPRINGS. ROLL UP
PRIVATE. AND SO FOUNDER THREE
AND ORDERS A WITH THEM SURE. WE
GOT THERE MISSION WORK ON. IF
YOU REMEMBER CANYON HOT SPRINGS
ON FEDERAL LAND WE'RE STILL
WORKING THROUGH THAT THE DAY WE
GOT OUR PERMITS FOR THESE OTHER
THINGS WAS THE DAY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT SHUTDOWN LAST
DECEMBER. SO WAS KIND OF A THAT
WAS A TWO MONTH CURVE BALL. BUT
SO AS OF. LAST. FOR THE NEXT
ONE UP. AFTER THE NEXT GONNA.
IN THE LAST TWO. I WAS UP THERE
THIS MORNING. ASKED TO NAME A
FINISHING ACOSTA QUESTIONS
WITHIN THE NEXT- TWENTY DAYS SO
THAT WILL BE DONE FOR THE
WINTER. BUT NONE OF THIS WOULD
HAVE HAPPENED HAD WE NOT HAD.
TO POUR OUT OF OUR COUNTY. AND.
THE WEAK COMPS I'D LISTEN WHEN.
VIA MAIL COMMUNITY OUR ARMY
CORPS OF ENGINEERS CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF FISH AND WILDLIFE
CALIFORNIA READER QUALITY
CONTROL BOARD ALL OF WHOM WE
NEEDED TO GET A PERMIT FROM THE
WHICH WE TOOK EVERYTHING
SERIOUSLY AND SATISFY THEIR
CONDITIONS AND- THESE ARE
TEMPORARY INSTALLATIONS THE
IDEA IS TO PROVIDE SOME LEVEL
PART- PROTECTION UNTIL THE-
THIRD THE GROUND THE GROUNDWORK
COVERS TO LEAVE GROWTH OCCURS
AND THE CONDITION STABILIZE SO
THIS ISN'T A PERMANENT SOLUTION
IT'S THIS IS A- SOMETHING TO
BUY IS THE TIME. UNTIL. THE
REWROTE THE CURVES AND NOT
RIGHT NOW I KNOW THE ACTIVATION
MAPS ARE BEING WITHDRAWN. AND
THEY ARE LOOKING AT THINGS LIKE
THAT THEIR PRODUCTION FOR THE
SEASON LOOKING AT THE RECALL
BOTH LOOKING AT THE USGS
REPORTS AND A NEW FACTOR THERE
CONSIDERING DECIDING WHAT'S
GOING TO BE IN THE RED ZONE AND
ARE NOT. IS THE RING. SO ANYWAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. WALGREENS
START TALKING- FORGET THE POWER
POINT PULLED UP WHICH I'M
REALIZING I PROBABLY DIDN'T
NEED TO DO BUT SINCE I PUT A
FEW SLIDES TOGETHER I WILL
SHARE WITH YOU. MY NAME IS
SUZANNE GRIMACING I WORK WITH
THE COUNTY OF SANTA BARBARA THE
DEPARTMENT OF BEHAVIORAL
WELLNESS I'VE BEEN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF QUITE SOMETIME
ABOUT TWENTY TWO YEARS AND- BY
DAY WHEN WE DON'T HAVE
DISASTERS HAPPENING I HAVE
CERTAIN ROLES IN THE
DEPARTMENT. BUT SOMETHING THAT
I FEEL PASSIONATE ABOUT THAT
I'VE HAD A CHANCE TO BE
INVOLVED AND THROUGHOUT MY TIME
WITH THE DEPARTURE. AND EVEN
MORE SO ON A RECENT YEARS. IS
COMMUNITY BEHAVIORAL HEALTH
DISASTER RESPONSE. SO I'M
INVOLVED IN THAT MANNER. I AM
INVOLVED WITH A LOT OF FIRST
RESPONDER TO BRIEFINGS- IN
SCHOOLS WITH WHAT WE CALL POST
TENSIONED ACTIVITIES ONE BAD
THIS HAPPENED IN THE SCHOOLS.
BUT I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU-
ONE OF THE MANY STORIES YOU'RE
HEARING TODAY ABOUT THE STORY
OF REALLY AMAZING REMARKABLE
COLLABORATION IN TERMS OF
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DISASTER
RESPONSE. AND WE SHOULD BE FOR
SURE THAT STORY I WOULD LIKE TO
SHARE. COLLABORATION THE
SOMETHING WE ALL DO THAT BRINGS
US ALL HEY. WHAT I REALLY.
MIDDLE COMPONENT. PATIENT I
MEAN THE PART IS INVOLVED.
POLLS COMMUNICATING. MAKING A
MESS THAT DOESN'T SOUND TOO
DIFFICULT. BUT AS I'M SURE MANY
OF YOU KNOW WHEN FORMING A
COLLABORATION IT CAN GET A
LITTLE TRICKIER THAN IT SOUNDS
ON PAPER. SO I'M SURE WITH YOU.
SOME FIRST ABOUT. THEY WELL.
CALL. WELLNESS THE CLASS ACTION
THERE WAS MORE AFTER THE TOP
SPOT SINCE EIGHTEEN IT WAS HOT
OR WAS RECOGNIZE EVEN MY
DEPARTMENT HAS THE NATION'S WE
DIDN'T HAVE THE BANDWIDTH TO
KEEP DOING OUR WORK AND TO
PROVIDE THE SERVICES NEEDED TO
THE COMMUNITY EVERYONE KNEW
THAT AND THE PHONE WAS RINGING
OFF THE HOOK WITH THERAPISTS
WITH ORGANIZATION SAYING CAN WE
HELP CAN WE HELP. I CAN DO THIS
BUT AS WE ALL KNOW WITHOUT A
COORDINATED EFFORT THAT
PROBABLY WOULDN'T HELP OUR
COMMUNITY AND IT WOULDN'T WE
WOULDN'T OF WORKED WELL
TOGETHER SO THAT'S ORGANIZATION
FORMED IT WAS BEGAN WITH
THIRTEEN ORGANIZATION. ALL
BLESSING KNOWING COULD DO THAT
ALONE AT A SURE. SEVEN WILL
HELP. WELL REMOTE NO ONE
SUPPORT. AND THAT SORT IS WHERE
YOU NEED A DEADLINE OF OUR
UNITY WHAT I BY THE IS THE
COMMUNITY WELLNESS TEAM
COLLECTIVELY PUT TOGETHER A
FULL CONTINUUM OF CARE ARRANGED
TO BUY OR FROM MEDIA CRISIS
RESPONSE CRITICAL INCIDENT
DEBRIEFING THIS SHORT TERM
THERAPY LONG TERM THERAPY GROUP
THERAPY SCHOOL BASED MENTAL
HEALTH ALL THE WAY UP TO AN
INTENSIVE OUTPATIENT PROGRAM AT
COTTAGE HOSPITAL. SO WITHIN THE
TEAM WE HAD A FULL CONTINUUM OF
CARE. THE DUGGAR COMMUNITY
WELLNESS TEAM IS LED BY
PARTMINER. IT'S CO CHAIRED BY
THE INSTITUTE FOR CLOSE TROUT
AND GROWTH IT'S. NO MY MIND IS
LOCATED THAT CERTAIN. WAS IT
THE CITY CENTER AND AT ANOTHER
LOCATION. THE COMMUNITY. IF NOT
ARE AT TELL YOU RIGHT NOW IT
WAS A WONDERFUL THING THAT I
THOUGHT IN TIME WOULD STOP AS
MANY OF THESE EFFORTS STILL. IT
HAS NOT STOPPED OUT ALL THIS
TEAM CONTINUES TO WORK TOGETHER
WITH THE SAME RESOURCES. AS IT
DID AT THE VERY START YOU'LL
HEAR FROM YOU NIELSEN A MOMENT
SHE'S WITH HOPE FIVE THAT WAS A
GRANT THAT BEHAVIOR A WELLNESS
SUPPLIED TO WITH FEMA FOR
CRISIS COUNSELORS. HOPE EIGHT
OH FIVE WAS A PART OF A GRANT
THAT ENDED AND YET YOU SEE
UNITS SITTING NEXT TO ME AND
YOU STILL SEE HOPE IT'LL FIVE
PARTNERS IN THE COMMUNITY SO
WHICH REALLY WORK TOGETHER. HOW
WE WORK THIS IS THE COMMUNITY
ON THIS TEAM IS A SUBGROUP THE
COMMUNITY. A GROUP THAT WAS
FORMED COMMUNITIES RECOVER FROM
THE BRIEF ON THOMAS WHERE. SIX
MONTHS TO THE THOMAS THERE WE
HAD BY THE TEN THOUSAND I HOPE.
THAT OR THE MULTIPLEX AND- SO
THE- TOGETHER AND THE FOCUS IS
YES BONDS BUT THEN IT'S BILL OF
BILLION SEE WITHIN OUR
COMMUNITY HELPING COMMUNITY TO
HELP THE TOOLS THAT ARE NEEDED
ONE MORE BAD THINGS HOW. THE
LONG TERM EFFECTS THEY CAN OPEN
AS A RESULT OF A TRAUMATIC
EVENT. THE SERVICES PROVIDED
RICHARD I JUST IN BUT THIS IS
ALSO A SHORTAGE COUNTY BEING
INDIVIDUAL FAMILY LONG COUNT.
COOL MY HOPE PRIMER ON CRITICAL
INCIDENT STRESS. IT'S ABOUT XIN
MAN. GOLD FOR. SOME EXAMPLE
RESPONSE IMMEDIATE CRISIS
RESPONSE WORK. ONCE AS EXACT
WHEN PEOPLE RETURN TO. RETURN
HOW MUCH THE STORE. HELLO THE
WELL IT WAS. I'M STOPPING OUR
PUBLIC FOR ME AND CALL MY FOR
LATEST SINCE THERE'S A LOCAL
SYSTEM SENATE. VERY MUCH. SURE.
AND THE OTHER ONCE THE
BRIEFINGS MORE NUMBER THREE
EVENTS. ONE THERE ARE A COUPLE
OF PICTURES BUT THE REASON THAT
I'M SHARING THE PICTURES. JUST
I HAVE A VERY STRONG BUT I
THINK LOAN. WHEN IT'S HAVE
RESPONDED SMALL. THREE AND THE
STRESS ACTION. THAT IS NOT
NECESSARILY AS- IT'S JUST AS A
RESULT. EVENT. MARBLE WITH THE
COMMUNITY WELLNESS NAME IS
THERE AT THE RIGHT TIME AND
PROVIDING THE RIGHT LEVEL IN
KIND OF SUPPORT NOT JUST FOR
INDIVIDUALS BUT FOR THE
COMMUNITY. CHANGE HER
EXPERIENCE WITH THOSE EVENTS.
IT'S NOT MAKE US STRONGER AS WE
GO FORWARD FOR OTHER DIFFICULT
THINGS THAT CAN HAPPEN. SO
YOU'LL SEE THESE ARE PICTURES
THE DON'T LOOK REGULAR. RIGHT.
THAT FALL EVEN THE. STATE HELP
DURING. WHAT. YEAH SPEND IT.
FOR THE CHOICE AND WE. THEY ARE
AND DINNER IS THERE ANY WAY WE
COULD GO TO THE DIVE BOAT SITE
AND JUST CITY WHERE OUR LOVED
ONES THIS WAS AT ABOUT EIGHT
O'CLOCK. FRIDAY NIGHT. CELL WE
CALLED THE COAST GUARD AND WE
MADE IT HAPPEN THE TOP RIGHT
SURE FAMILIES A LOT. WELLNESS
SCOTT THAT WAS IT. RECOVERY
PROCESS. THE BOTTOM AFTER A
BRIEF WHAT THE HELL. YOU SEE
HAPPY THIS IS A LITTLE BIT.
THEY WERE THE ONES THE BOTTOM
LEFT. THAT WAS WITHIN THE BREED
THAT SCHOOL LOST. THEY GOT
THIRTY THIRD BENCH. THIS
PICTURE YOU MAY BE FAMILIAR
WITH THAT'S OUR MOST RECENT
CONCEPTION DIE BOTH VIGIL SAID.
WELL MY NAME IS A. EIGHT HELLO.
FEELING AND HOW. REMEMBER. BILL
NEXT PREVENTS THE PROGRESSION
OF STRESS AND DISTRESS TO
LONGER TERM IMPACTS. REALIZES
THAT NONE OF US US COULD DO ANY
OF THIS WITHOUT THE CLUB
QUESTION AMONG THE STEAM. WE
HAVE A LOT OF THINGS TO DO WE
HAVE BROCHURES WHICH ALL HELP
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SEE SOME I
HAVE A TWO PAGE DESCRIPTION
ABOUT US WE HAVE TO UPDATE THEM
THEY SAY THEY'RE BECAUSE-
THOMAS FIRE IN A FREE FLOW WHEN
IN FACT THIS COMMUNITY WELLNESS
TEAM. BUT TO LIVE WE HAVE A
WEBSITE WELCOME TO GO TO IT. IT
UP THEY- WERE HERE. SO HERE'S
SOME CONTACT HIM ALL LEAVE
THESE MATERIALS IF YOU'D LIKE
TO COLLECT THANK YOU MUCH.
HELLO EVERYONE MY NAME IS A
UNIT THAT I ME UP AND I STARTED
WORKING- INTO DIFFERENT
CAPACITY- WITHIN THE NONPROFIT
IN THE STATION. FIRST WITH
UNITED WAY ACCORDINGLY. SENATE
REBUILDING- AND THEN AS A
MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA HOPE
TEAM AND THEN BLANK. YOUR
PARTNER THE MENTAL ILLNESS
CENTER IN COLLABORATION WITH-
COUNTY BEHAVIORAL WELLNESS- AND
WE WERE FUNDED IF YOU. SO NOW
OF BOTH OF THESE ROLES. AS THE
RECOVERY ASSISTANT COUNTY OF
SANTA BARBARA. ALONG WITH MY
COLLEAGUES WHO WAS ALSO
CALIFORNIA HOPE IT'LL TO. V. MY
ROLE IN THE WANT TO SEE THOSE
CENTER I THINK. THE BETWEEN.
JUST BECAUSE THERE WAS IT
SERVED AS THE ONE STOP SHOP FOR
THE MOST AFFECTED AND MULTIPLE
WONDERFUL POPULATION- WE HAD
WRAPS THAT WE HAD REVISOR
WILLIAMS THERE WE HAD- BRIGADE
HAD OUR WHOLE TEAM WHICH WAS-
SIX CRISIS. COUNSELORS HAVE
THEM WHERE. WE HAD WE'VE THERE
WAS ECONOMIC VENTURES. WE HAD-
EIGHT OH FIVE CONSERVATION OF.
MOST OF THE VERY. THEY'RE BUILT
THAT WERE LOST IN THE DEBRIS
FLOW. WE ALSO HAVE OKAY OKAY.
HE HOSTED VARIOUS DIFFERENT
AGENCIES OR PROP AND
GOVERNMENTAL AGENCIES AND THAT.
AND AFTER THE IT KIND OF FROM
MY I WAS KIND OF LIKE THE FIRST
PHASE EVERYONE SIGNED THE
CENTER WHEN THEY FIRST CAME IN-
AND FOR MY SENSE IT KIND TO GET
INSIDE TO THE CAN- TO THE
GOVERNMENT AGENCIES AS WELL AS-
AS WELL AS- WE HAD A FEMALE. ON
AS WELL AND IT KIND OF. DID NOT
KNOW. WHAT TO DO. I MEAN THERE
ARE AMONG THOSE EARLY WE. I
WILL THE WARMTH- THAT THE
WOULDN'T REALLY HAVE- IF THE
CENTER WASN'T THERE ON GROUND
ZERO. BUT. IT REALLY IT REALLY.
AND IT REALLY MADE ME REALIZE
THAT PART. TRANSITION INTO MY
ROLE WITH CALIFORNIA-
CALIFORNIA HOPE DID REALLY A
LOT OF OUR REGION A LOT OF
EDUCATION A LOT OF. MENTAL
HEALTH FIRST AID TO KIND OF
GIVING PEOPLE TOOLS OF FOR
COPING SKILLS GOING TO THE
POLLS I MEAN EVEN BEING BROWN
BLOCKING ON DOORS JUST CHECK IN
ON PEOPLE AND REALLY MAKING
SURE. ONE WAS OKAY AND THE
ASSURING THEM THAT THEY WERE
STILL HELP OUT. WE SERVE. XIN
TO BRIDGE THE GAP WITH. AB A
RECENT THAT PEOPLE MIGHT NOT
BEEN AWARE OF. ANYWHERE FROM
HELPING THEM APPLY TO GROUND TO
DIRECT RELIEF AROUND THE UNITED
WAY GRANTS ALL THAT. ALL THAT
THE PEOPLE MIGHT HAVE BEEN
AWARE OF. ALSO A LOT OF OUT
REACH AGAIN- WAS DONE IN THE
LATINO COMMUNITY- WITH THE HELP
OF A LOT OF TRUSTED PARTNER IN
THE COMMUNITY. A LOT OF US ARE
KNOWN- ONE THANK YOU VERY MUCH-
A LOT OF SPANISH OUT REACH WE
HAD A REALLY GOOD- COMMUNITY
MEETING ACCESS OR NOT I THOUGHT
THEY HAD A TREMENDOUS-
ATTENDANCE IT WAS AMAZING AND
WE WERE ABLE TO RIGHT THEN AND
THERE- REGISTER PEOPLE FOR A
WHERE. PREPARE FOR NEXT SOUL OR
JUST KIND OF. GIVING THEM THOSE
TOOLS TO BE ABLE TO PREPARE
THEIR FAMILIES IN CASE OF
ANYTHING THAT WOULD COME UP-
KIND OF. REALLY EDUCATING AND-
LETTING THEM KNOW THAT WE ARE
HERE TO HELP WE WERE ABLE TO
REALLY ASSIST AND- GETTING THEM
PREPARED AND THAT THEY'RE STILL
RESOURCES OUT THERE IF THEY'RE
LACKING ANY. SO. THIS
COLLABORATION BETWEEN NONPROFIT
GOVERNMENT IS I THINK IT. YEAH.
SO HOW IS EVERYONE DOING
GETTING HUNGRY AND. DON'T WORRY
THE FOOD BANK IS HERE- SO MY
NAME IS DEREK TALKING ON THE
SEA OF THE FOOD BANK SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS- GRAIN FOR INVITING US
HERE SO HOW WE KEEP PEOPLE FED
THE EVENT OF A MAJOR DISASTER.
I'M JUST GONNA BRIEFLY EXPLAIN
WHAT THE FOOD BANK DOESN'T A
DAILY BASIS AND THEN HOW WE IF
IT THAT DURING A DISASTER
SITUATION SO WE OPERATE EVERY
DAY BASICALLY SOURCING STORING
AND DISTRIBUTING FOOD AROUND
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY. WE
DISTRIBUTE TEN MILLION POUNDS
OF FOOD PER YEAR THREE THREE
HUNDRED MEMBER AGENCY
ORGANIZATIONS SO A LOT OF YOUR
FAVORITE ORGANIZATIONS THEY
COME TO THE FEEDBACK THEY GET
THEIR FOOD- AND HALF OF WHAT WE
DISTRIBUTE FRESH PRODUCE- SO WE
ARE CURRENTLY PROVIDING FOOD TO
REALLY AN INCREDIBLE ONE IN
FOUR PEOPLE IN THIS COUNTY. SO
IT MIGHT BE IN VERY SMALL WAYS
IN TERMS OF SOME FOOD FOR SOME
FRUIT FOR HEAD START PROGRAM
RIGHT THROUGH TO SENIORS WHO WE
MIGHT BE PROVIDE LONG TERM
SUPPORT TO- AND TYPICALLY
PEOPLE THAT WERE WORKING WITH
ARE THE WORKING POOR WE'RE
GETTING NEAR THE END OF THAT
AND THEIR PAY PERIOD AND YOU
KNOW ARE REALLY STRUGGLING IN
OUR FOOD IN SECURE. THAT'S A
HUGE CHALLENGE FOR US- WE ALSO
RUN A NATIONAL AWARD WINNING
FOOD LITERACY PROGRAMS THAT
HELP ARMS KIDS STARTING AT
PRESCHOOL LEVEL RIGHT UP TO YOU
HIGH SCHOOL ABOUT HOW TO BE
HEALTHY WITH FOOD AND WATER THE
PRACTICAL SKILLS INVOLVED. SO
THAT'S HOW WE DEAL WITH WHAT IS
THE DAILY DISASTER OF ANGER BUT
WHAT ABOUT WHEN THERE IS- AND
THIS IS AN IMMEDIATE DISASTER
THAT AFFECTS A HUGE AMOUNT OF
COMMUNITY. WE FEEL THAT OUR
LOGISTICAL AND NETWORK STRIP
THAT WE USE EVERY DAY ARE
ACTUALLY VITAL ORGAN DURING
THIS ACTOR- SO WHERE THE
PRIMARY. USDA TO THAT WOULD
COME IN FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
DURING A DISASTER. AND WE'RE
RESPONSIBLE FOR REPEATING. A
LOT OF THE SCHOOLS WERE SHUT
DOWN- AND THEN. TO THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE GETTING FREE AND
REDUCED. CHEST SO THOSE KIDS
WERE SUFFERING- AND SO WE WERE
ABLE TO PUT ON- LUNCH MEALS FOR
THOSE PEOPLE. I'M AND THEN WHEN
MANY OF OUR MEMBER AGENCIES
WERE NOT ABLE TO OPERATE DURING
THE FIRE BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T
WANT TO SEND AND THEIR STAFF
OUT INTO THE YOU KNOW DANGEROUS
AIR QUALITY CONDITIONS. WE HAD
TO SET UP NEW DISTRIBUTIONS
THAT TAKE AWAY TYPICALLY TOOK
PLACE INDOORS BECAUSE OF THESE
CALIFORNIA ALL THE
DISTRIBUTIONS WERE OUTSIDE
BEFORE- AND THAT ENABLED US TO
MAKE USE OF FIFTEEN HUNDRED-
NEIGHBORHOOD OF VOLUNTEERS WE
HAVE. THEY SAY THAT IN A
DISASTER A BY THE SECOND DAY
YOUR PLAN DISASTER PLAN THE ONE
THAT YOU SPENT ABOUT DOLLARS.
COMING UP WITH A ITS KIND OF IN
THE DUMPER- AND WATCHED HAVE TO
RELY ON IS THE RELATIONSHIP
THAT YOU DEVELOP OVER A PERIOD
OF TIME. WITH OTHER SERVICE
PROVIDERS- AND THAT'S CERTAINLY
BEEN THE YOU KNOW A BIG LESSON
FOR US. SO OVER THE LAST FEW
MONTHS WE'VE BEEN WORKING
INTENSIVELY WITH LOCAL
COMMUNITY PARTNERS- SUCH AS THE
COUNTY OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT THE RED CROSS AND
SALVATION ARMY. TO PUT TOGETHER
A DISASTER FEEDING PLAN FOR THE
COUNTY- YOU KNOW THE COUNTY HAS
A DISASTER PLAN BUT THAT
DOESN'T ACTUALLY HAVE A FEEDING
PLAN ELEMENT IN IT. SO WE'VE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS PLAN BRING
TOGETHER ALL THE PARTNERS. THAT
WILL ENABLE US TO OPERATE-
DURING A DISASTER- WE'RE
PUTTING TOGETHER DISASTER
FEEDING TASK FORCE THAT WILL
MEET EVERY YEAR AND CHANGE THE
PLAN AND TRAIN AROUND THE PLAN.
SO HOPEFULLY. A PLAN THAT LAYS
OUT LAST BEYOND DAY TO.
DISASTER SO WHAT IS REALLY KEY
FOR US IS OUR ABILITY TO
LEVERAGE NETWORK SO I TALK
ABOUT THREE HUNDRED LOCAL
NONPROFIT AGENCIES. THOSE ARE
REALLY AGENCIES AGO FROM LARGE
TO TIENEN THEY'RE ALL OVER THE-
THE DIFFERENT NEIGHBORHOODS OF
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY. AND ALSO
A LOT OF AGENCIES WON'T BE ABLE
TO RUN IN THE DISASTER SO WE'RE
GONNA HAVE TO RELY ON A WHOLE.
CRAZY QUILT DIFFERENT AGENCIES.
I WE ALSO RELY ON REGIONAL FOOD
BANKS SO YOU KNOW DURING THE.
THOMAS DISASTER WE COULDN'T GET
FOOD. PRINTER. BECAUSE THE ONE
A ONE SHUT DOWN. SO WITHIN ONE
DAY THOSE PROGRAM. TO BE
RESUPPLIED OUR SISTER FEEDBACK
IN VENTURA. WE HAVE A THEIR
FOOD BANKS IN SLOW COUNTY- IN
BAKERSFIELD AND FRESNO. SO FOOD
CAN COME IN FOR LOCALLY VERY
QUICK TO US. AND THEN ALSO WERE
MEMBERS OF A NATIONAL NETWORK
WHICH COLD FEET AMERICA. THE
NET TWO HUNDRED. AND BASED IN
TWENTY SEVEN BASS MILLIONS OF
HOW WOULD. FROM THAT WERE MADE
TO THE U. S. SO IT'S REALLY A
VITAL SO AT THE FOOD BANK
REALLY LEARN THOMAS AFTER WE
HAVE A NEW DESIGN I'M ENGINEER
STARTING THE WEEK. THANKS FOR
TRAINING. AND ALSO WE'RE
DEVELOPING A NEW CADRE OF
DISASTER VOLUNTEERS WHO WILL
HELP BILL TO MAINTAIN THESE
NEIGHBORHOOD DISTRIBUTIONS- SO
THEY NEVER REALLY LACKING AT
THE MOMENT IS IN IMPROVE SOUTH
COUNTY- OUR FACILITY SO IT'S
OKAY TO ASK FOR HELP RIGHT THE
DISASTER AND EVEN BEFORE
DISASTER SO WE HAVE A SOUTH
COUNTY FACILITY THAT'S VERY
KINDLY- LEASED. BY THE COUNTY
SANTA BARBARA I'M A BIT. OUR
STATE. FOOD FROM OUR NORTH
CANTON WAREHOUSE WOULD NOT BE
ABLE TO GET DOWN THE ONE A ONE
SO WE'RE LOOKING AT TRYING TO
FIND THE SITE TO DEVELOP AN
EMERGENCY FOOD STORE FOR THE
SOUTHERN OF PART OF SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY SO IT'S GOING TO
TAKE SEVERAL DAYS FOR FOOD BILL
TO COME IN FROM AIR OR FROM C.
SO WE REALLY NEED TO HAVE SOME
FOOD ON HAND FOR MULTIPLE DAYS
TO BE ABLE TO KEEP PEOPLE FED
HERE. SO. I ASK- SO. YOU SO
MUCH FOR INVITING US HERE TO
TAKE PART. IT'S ALL OF OUR
PANELISTS. START AT SHE THE
CONVERSATION NO I'VE HAD THE
FIRST HAND EXPERIENCE OF
WORKING WITH ALL. NOT JUST IN
IN IN THE NATURAL DISASTER A
RESPONSE MOMENTS BUT IN OTHER
MOMENTS AND ONE OF THE THINGS.
THAT TO US IT COMES TO MINE IS.
HOW IT IS WHAT YOU. SCALE UP.
THE OTHER COUNTY ARE THERE THE
STATE. I'LL SURE FOR MY
EXPERIENCE WOULD BE GREAT IF
THE ROOM DOES TOO SO. OR NOT.
MY BROTHER COUNTY. WORKS SHARE
IT. AND THAT'S WHAT HELPS US
ALL TO GET GOING SO SAVE FOR MY
CELL MONO STATEWIDE OF. THE
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT HEALTH
CARE SERVICES ON A STATE WIDE
WORKGROUP LOOKING AT BEHAVIORAL
HEALTH DISASTER RESPONSE. THE
WORLD IS A SMALL WORKGROUP
PUTTING TO OTHER A TOOL KIT FOR
THE STATE AND THEN A TOOL KIT
FOR COUNTIES THAT'S ONE AYE BUT
IT'S MORE THAN THAT IT'S A WAY
OF SHARING EXPERIENCES HAVING A
CHANCE TO REPLICATE- WE DO A
LOT OF CONSULTATION ALSO WITH
OTHER COUNTIES EVEN AS RECESS
BI&LT;C.CYAN&GT;. COMING ACROSS THEIR ONE&LT;/C&GT;
YEAR AND- AT. THE SURFACE
WITHOUT SO WE DO A LOT OF
TALKING WITH OTHER COUNTY THIS
IS ALL. SO THAT SOME OF THE
WAYS THAT WE DON'T. FOR A FOR
THE FIRST RESPONDER POINT OF
VIEW IT IS RECOGNIZED IT'S.
RECOGNIZING THAT THERE IS A
PROBLEM. AND THAT'S IT WHAT
WHAT WE DISCOVERED- ESPECIALLY
THOMAS FUNDED FOR THE FIRST
TIME EVER EVERYBODY THAT
RESPONDED- WE HAD TO GO TO A
MENTAL HEALTH DEBRIEFING WHAT
WILL THEY WANTED ACCESS OR NOT
THEY HAD TO BE BRIEF. AND THAT
BRAND NEW NEVER HAPPENED FOR
THE WOULDN'T OF BEEN EVEN
CONCEIVABLE THREE OR FOUR YEARS
AGO BUT THE FOR THE FIRST TIME
UNITED STATES LAST. YEAR MORE
FIREFIGHTERS DIED BY SUICIDE IN
THE TRAUMA. AND SO IT YEAH IT'S
RECOGNIZING THE TOLL THAT.
THESE EXPERIENCES TAKE ON
INDIVIDUALS IN THE COMMUNITY
AND I SCALING IT UP I THINK
IT'S JUST RECOGNIZED A LOT OF
IS JUST RECOGNIZING HOW
WIDESPREAD THE PROBLEM IS AND-
IN A BIG BIG THEY COUNTIES
THAT- NGO BUT THINGS ARE THERE
PROVIDING THESE SERVICES ARE
THERE ARE GROWING. AT THE END
GROWING IN RECOGNITION OF THE
PROBLEM. SO REMEMBER THANK YOU
FOR THE QUESTION YOU KNOW HOW
WE WOULD SAY THAT- THAT WE
RECOGNIZE THAT WE JUST DON'T
HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES HERE
LOCALLY TO MEET A MARATHON OF A
RECOVERY PERIOD. HE HAD LEAN
HEAVILY ON OUR PARTNERS FROM
THE OTHER COUNTY IS THE CITIES
IN JURISDICTIONS ONE OF THE
THINGS WE DO IS. WE SHARE
RESOURCES REALLY WELL HERE AND
IN. WITH THE CITY AND- ANY
OTHER SPECIAL DISTRICTS WE
SHARE RESOURCES WE SHARE- WEEK
WE GO UP AND DOWN THE STATE WE
TALK ABOUT OUR EXPERIENCES HERE
AND DO A LITTLE BIT OF LESSONS
LEARNED WITH OTHER. WITH OTHER
EXECUTIVES- AND ALSO LOCAL
LOCALLY. WE HAVE A GOOD
UNDERSTANDING OF WHAT OTHER
RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE OUTSIDE
THE COUNTY SO THAT HE
UNDERSTOOD THE SAN LUIS
RECURRENT VENTURA HAS. AND
ANOTHER ONE WAS DE CONFLICTING-
AREAS THAT YOU MIGHT HAVE
POTENTIAL CONFLICTS AND YOU
KNOW THE THOMAS FIRE STARTED
VENTURA COUNTY AS- WELL AS IN.
THE USE OF DIFFERENT MATIX SOME
DIFFERENT TERMINOLOGY AS WE-
IT'S WORKING ON THOSE KIND OF
THINGS YOU KNOW BEFORE THE
EVENT BEFORE THE EMERGENCY TO
MAKE SURE. FIRST TO TYPE FAMILY
HERE ON. POST YOU KNOW WE HAVE
A LOT OF EMPLOYEES LIVE
INVENTOR A LOT OF- PEOPLE CAN
YOU SOUTH OF PEOPLE COMMUTE
NORTH TO BE YOURSELF. WE ARE
ALL RELIED ON EACH OTHER AND
THE MORE WE CAN SHARE RESOURCES
AND OUR EXPERIENCES THAT ARE
OFFERED IN THE. I'M A DOUBLE
DOWN ON THAT QUESTION AND MAYBE
PUSH BACK AND CHALLENGE YOU
GUYS BUT. THE TWO COUNTIES THAT
HAVE THE MOST NONPROFITS PER
CAPITA IN THE STATE ARE SANTA
BARBARA. NOW SOME OF YOU MAY
THINK THAT'S BECAUSE THE
MAJORITY OF SOCIETY SOCIAL ILLS
EXIST IN MARIN COUNTY AND SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY. YEAH I SAY THAT
JUST OBVIOUSLY BUT- BUT BUT BUT
IT DOES IT DOES BEG THE
QUESTION THAT I SHALL NEVER
LEMOND BROUGHT UP WHICH IS HOW
DO WE TAKE YOU KNOW WE HAVE
WHAT WE HAVE IS A CONCENTRATION
OF. WEALTH GENEROSITY NON
PROFITS- EXPERIENCE AND HOW DO
WE TAKE THAT AND APPLY THE
LESSONS LEARNED. TO COUNTIES
YOUR STATEWIDE THAT DON'T HAVE
THOSE RESOURCES RIGHT. I THINK
THERE'S YOUR THAT'S REALLY THE
BEST TAKE AWAY FROM TODAY I'M
EXCITED TO WORK WITH MY
COLLEAGUES HERE AND FIGURE OUT
HOW WE CAN FOLLOW UP VIA SAMAT
IT'S MUCH INSTALLATION WORKING
WITH SOME OF THE PANELISTS IN
YOUR ORGANIZATIONS TO TAKE SOME
OF THIS AND- BECAUSE IT IS
CONCERNING THAT. I COUNTY WHERE
THERE'S ENORMOUS PHILANTHROPIC
WHERE THERE'S ENORMOUS. YELLOW
EXPERTISE- AN ENORMOUS- WEALTH
AND FEDERAL BUT WE STILL
STRUGGLE TO MEET THE DEMANDS OF
THESE HORRIFIC INCIDENTS RIGHT.
AND SO WHAT WE DO YEAH- YOU'LL
A MERCED COUNTY OR A. YOUR KERN
COUNTY KINGS COUNTY. PLACES
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE THAT THAT
THAT THAT SAME SUPPORT STOP.
I'M KIND OF CURIOUS ON THE
SCALING I'D LIKE TO THINK ABOUT
SCALING NOT IS WORKING WITH
OTHER PARTNERS AS MUCH AS- WE
ARE. HOW DO WE ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF THE LEAST AMONG US
WHEN IT COMES TO THE LEASE
RESOURCE COUNTIES WITH THE
LEAST NUMBER. I'LL JUMP IN WITH
I MEAN I THINK WE ALSO NEED TO
REMEMBER THAT- YEAH IF WE TALK
ABOUT THE NEEDS OF PEOPLE-
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY THERE'S
ANY THREE COUNTIES IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE MORE FOOD
INSECURITY THAN HERE. ONE FOR
CHILDREN THAT IN SANTA BARBARA
COUNTY IS LIVING IN POVERTY- SO
THERE'S A KIND OF STARK FIGURES
THAT ARE UNDERNEATH THE- THE
WEALTH AND EVERYTHING THAT'S
BUT I AGREE THE IN TERMS OF
SERVICES SO IT IS DOWN TO US I
MEAN WE AS AN ORGANIZATION.
SHARE WITH ALL OUR PART TO
BANKS. CALIFORNIA THROUGHOUT
THE NATION TERMS OF SHARING
WHAT WE'VE LEARNED IN OUR
SKILLS- BUT THEN ALSO LOOKING
AT HOW NATIONALLY WE CAN RE
DIRECT- FOOD. DONATIONS TO AREA
THAT MOST NEED IT SO THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WERE ACTIVELY
INVOLVED IN DISCUSSING. LOCALLY
WOULD FREAK OUT IF WE TOOK OUR
FOOD AND GAVE IT TO ANOTHER-
COUNTY OR STATE PEOPLE VERY
PROPRIETARY ABOUT HUNGER. AND
IT BEING A LOCAL SOLUTION BUT
WE FEEL THAT AT A NATIONAL
LEVEL THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE
CAN ACHIEVE. I THINK FOR. BY
GOING BACK TO THE FIRE MODEL
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT WE'RE
TRULY GOING TO BE AS A COMMAND
SYSTEM FOR US AND ONE OF THAT.
AND THAT'S OUR MUTUAL AID GETS
THROUGH THIS WHOLE STATE AND
THE WHOLE. GOAL WESTERN UNITED
STATES. AND ONE OF THE THINGS
THE FIRE SCOPE WHICH IS THE
GOVERNING. ORGANIZATION FOR
THAT STARTED A MENTAL HEALTH
PHONE. A COUPLE YEARS AGO AND
WE HAVE LOCAL. LOCAL LEADERS ON
THAT COMMITTEE- VETERAN SANTA
BARBARA COUNTY LOS ANGELES
COUNTY NOW BUT THEY PROVIDE.
MENTAL HEALTH THROUGH EVERY
AREAS IT'S GOVERNED BY IT'S A
COMMAND SYSTEM AND FIRE SCOPE
IN CALIFORNIA RIGHT NOW SO
THERE IS A MUTUAL AID. CAPACITY
NOW THAT COULD BE MONICA YOU I
THINK COULD BE USED AS A MODEL
FOR AGENCIES LIKE TO VAN THAT
THE TO START NETWORKING. THE
SAME WAY THAT YOU BUILD MUTUAL
AID FOR WHAT. YOU'RE BUILDING.
DIFFERENT TYPE OF EMERGENCY
RESPONSE HOW WHICH IS BEING
RECOGNIZED AS MENTAL HEALTH. AS
A MENTAL HEALTH AFTER EFFECTS
OF TRAUMA BY DUE TO INCIDENTS.
I AGREE MUCH. I THINK WE'RE
INCREDIBLY BLESSED TO HAVE THE
RESOURCES WE DO IN THIS COUNTY
AND I DO RECOGNIZE NOT ALL
COUNTIES HAVE THAT BUT I CAN
SAY I AM CERTAIN THAT ALL THOSE
RESOURCES ALL THOSE
ORGANIZATIONS ARE NOT NEEDED
AND MY CASE WITH BEHAVIORAL
WELLNESS RESPONSE BABY RALPH
RESPONSE AND THE REASON WHY
IT'S A CULTURE CHANGE JUST LIKE
YOU HAD DESCRIBED THE MENTAL
HEALTH DEBRIEFINGS THAT OCCUR
WITH FIRST RESPONDERS. MANY
TIMES A COMMUNITY THEY MAY NOT
FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE THE
RESOURCES AND THEREFORE NEED TO
REQUEST FROM THE OUTSIDE BUT
THE REALITY IS THAT'S NOT TRUE
IT'S TRAINING I HEARD THAT
MENTAL HEALTH FOR TOSSED OUT IS
A TERM PSYCHOLOGICAL FIRST AID
WHICH IS UNIQUELY THAT TRAINING
FOR PER DISASTER RESPONSE.
ANYBODY CAN BE AND ON THAT.
I'VE. HERE IN OUR COUNTY WHO.
EXPERIENCED A SUICIDES WE HAD
ONE SCHOOL THAT HAD THE SUICIDE
OF FIVE SENIORS AND ONE WILL
NOT SUICIDES ONE WITH THE DEATH
OF THE DEBRIS FLOW BUT LOST
FIVE SENIORS AND ONE YEAR. THAT
SCHOOL WAS WELL EQUIPPED FOR
THAT THE REASON THEY WORDS WE
HAD RESPONDED IN THE PAST. AND
WE HAD WORKED TOGETHER AND
SETTING UP SYSTEM SO THAT WHEN
THINGS CAME AND HIT I KNOW HOW
TO RESPOND WITH THEIR INTERNAL
CAPACITIES. SO THERE'S WAYS TO
SET THAT UP IN ANY COMMUNITY NO
MATTER THE SIZE IT'S GIVING.
PEOPLE NEED IT'S WONDERFUL TO
HAVE LICENSED THERAPIST THAT'S
NOT REQUIRED FOR MIDDLE HOLD US
TO RESPONSE. SO SOMEONE
EMIGRATE APPRECIATE THE
QUESTION AND I THINK A LOT OF
THAT. LEATHER IS BACK TO.
EDUCATION WHAT WE'VE BEEN
THROUGH HOW TO LEVERAGE THESE
KIND OF THINGS LIKE TODAY'S
HEARING WAS MEANT TO DO BUT IT
REALLY IS THAT- SOME OF THOSE
MODELS EXIST IF YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT SOME OF THE RURAL
COUNTIES UP IN NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA- ACROSS OUR CENTRAL
VALLEY THERE ARE A LOT OF
GROUPS THERE ARE OF A LOT THERE
ARE A LOT OF UNITING OF
DIFFERENT DIFFERENT PARTS OF
THOSE COUNTIES THEY DO COME
TOGETHER MONTHLY QUARTERLY AND
DIFFERENT TYPES OF DEPARTMENTS
FOR DIFFERENT KINDS OF
INITIATIVES. I THINK LEVERAGES
SOME OF THOSE RELATIONSHIPS
WILL HELP START BUILD LÀ MORE
AND WITH AND THOSE SAME THINGS
THOSE SAME PRINCIPLES APPLY TO
THE NONPROFIT TO THE OTHER
AGENCIES YOU KNOW- A LOT OF THE
AGENCIES HERE TODAY AND WE WORK
WITH REGULARLY ARE NOT JUST
SPECIFIC TO ONE COUNTY THERE AS
YOU KNOW ACROSS THE COUNTY
ACROSS THE REGION ACROSS THE
COUNTRY AND I THINK THAT- THEY
DON'T LOOK CARRIES AS
GEOGRAPHIC TO DEVISE A LOOK AT
OUR COMMUNITIES AND OFFER HELP
WILL THEY CAN AND I REALLY DO
THINK THAT. THAT THOSE. THOSE
COLLABORATIONS ACROSS THE STATE
WHERE THERE'S- A THERE'S A NEED
AND I'VE I'VE SEEN SOME OF THEM
WHEN IT COMES TO WATER AND
WATER CONSERVATION BETWEEN
SEVERAL RURAL COUNTIES OR- IN-
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMUNICATIONS
INFRASTRUCTURE. WHERE THEY NEED
TO RELY ON EACH OTHER'S TOWERS
TO. BOOST THOSE MICROWAVE.
SIGNALS ON THE PUBLIC RADIO-
SAFETY NETWORK AL. COMP
OBVIOUSLY IN THE FIRE FIRST
RESPONDER- ARENAS- OUR SHARE OF
DISASSOCIATION TO HAVE
AGREEMENTS- BETWEEN ALL OF
THEMSELVES HELP EACH OTHER OUT.
THEY NEED TO. RESOURCES AND
RELATIONSHIPS AND TAKEN THE
NEXT LEVEL. THE QUOTED UP FOR
SOME MORE QUESTIONS OUT HERE
WILL START RIGHT HERE IN THE
MIDDLE IN FRONT OF ME OUR OUT.
WE'LL GET RIGHT TO YOU YOUR
NUMBER TWO WELL FIRST OF ALL
I'D LIKE TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
YOUR- WORK- HERE IN THE
COMMUNITY AND ALSO FOR YOUR
COMMENTS TODAY. PAT ALLUDED IN
HIS LAST ANSWER TO MY QUESTION
WHICH IS IN. OUR LEARNING
PROCESS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
LEARNING HOW TO DEAL WITH THE
NATURAL DISASTERS WE FACE-
FIRST RESPONDERS- REALIZE THAT
THERE WAS A NEED TO HAVE A
SYSTEM FOR COORDINATION AND
THAT THE INCIDENT COMMAND
SYSTEM DEVELOPED OUT OF THAT
AND WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN REPEATED
DISASTERS HERE IN CALIFORNIA IS
A REALLY HIGH LEVEL OF
COOPERATION AND COORDINATION IN
THE FIRST RESPONSE BUT WHEN THE
RESCUE PHASE OF A DISASTER IS
OVER. AND WE GO INTO WHAT WE
CALL THE SECOND RESPONSE WHICH
IS EVEN RECOVER- THERE IS NO
SYSTEM LIKE THAT- TO COORDINATE
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT VOLUNTEER
GROUPS AND SO WE SEE- IN
GENERAL LESS COOPERATION AND
COORDINATION AMONG ALL OF THE
DIFFERENT PLAYERS IN RECOVERY
AND AS CLIMATE CHANGE INCREASES
THE THREAT MATRIX AND THE
FREQUENCY AND SCOPE OF THE
DISASTERS WERE FACING MY
QUESTION TO YOU IS IT TIME FOR
US TO CONSIDER SOME KIND OF
INCIDENT COMMAND SYSTEM FOR THE
SECOND RESPONSE IN DECLARED
DISASTERS AND IF SO HOW WOULD
WE- GO ABOUT DOING THAT. WHAT
VI&LT;C.CYAN&GT; YES OF COURSE- THERE'S&LT;/C&GT;
THERE THERE THAT THEY HAVE.
FRAMEWORK TO THAT VERY WELL BOB
VO AD IS ONE SUCH ORGANIZATION
BUT THE- THE- SO MUCH OF IT IS
A RECOGNIZING OF THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE. THAT ARE. WORKING AS
A SECOND RESPOND IS FINDING OUT
WHO EACH OTHER LOUIS FOR THERE
ARE BECAUSE I CAN TELL YOU
SOMEBODY THAT WAS- BACK IN THE
MISTS OF TIME WAS AROUND WHEN
THE INCIDENT COMMAND SYSTEM.
STARTED WE DIDN'T GET ALONG. WE
WERE JUST THERE AT THE SAME
PLACE BUT WE WERE COMMUNICATING
WELL- WE WERE SHARING. AND IF
IT DID TAKE IT FOR FOUR DECADES
TO GET TO WHERE. YOU KNOW IT
THE THOMAS FIRE YEAH THE
LARGEST MUTUAL AID RESPONSE FOR
FIRE AND HISTORY UNITED STATES
EIGHTY SEVEN HUNDRED PEOPLE.
HERE AND THAT KIND OF GOT LOST
WITH THE DEBRIS FLOW BUT- THE
RECOGNITION OF THAT BUT- IT
IT'S. IT'S BEEN FIGHTING TO GET
THROUGH TO GET THE
COMMUNICATION BETTER BECAUSE
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A FRAMEWORK IN
AND THEN YOU'RE YOU'RE
POPULATED BUT IT ISN'T GONNA
COME EASY IT'S NOT GOING TO
COME UP. WITHOUT RESISTANCE
THAT'S NOT CONNECT. WITH A
BREAKING DOWN SOME WALLS. I CAN
ANSWER THAT ON BEHALF OF THE
STATE THANK YOU THE- AND HE THE
MAX SYSTEM. YEARS IN ROWS TO
GET IT RIGHT WE ARE STARTED
WITH THE CALIFORNIA DISASTER
RECOVERY FRAMEWORK THAT HAS
BEEN PUT INTO PLACE COUNTIES
ARE DEVELOPING THAT AND THERE
ARE RECOVERY SUPPORT FUNCTIONS
THAT MATCH OUR EMERGENCY
SUPPORT FUNCTIONS AND THERE ARE
ECONOMIC THEIR HEALTH AND HOPE
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES
HOUSING INFRASTRUCTURE. I DON'T
NATURAL CULTURAL RESOURCES. BUT
THE POINT IS THAT IT TOOK US
MANY MANY YEARS AND MANY MANY
TRIALS AND HUGE TO PASTORS IN
ORDER TO GET TO WORK OUR WITH
THE INCIDENT COMMAND SYSTEM
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY AND WE.
ARE DOING THAT ON THE FOR THE
RECOVERY SIDE BECAUSE WE
RECOGNIZE THAT THERE'S A HUGE
AGE GAP. AND SO WE ARE WORKING
ON IT I WANTED THANKS FOR THAT.
THOUGHT OF. IT IS AB AND WE'RE
TRYING TO FILL IT. GOOD
QUESTION I'D LIKE TO SEE SOME
RECOMMENDATIONS FROM THE
DEPARTMENT. SO WILL FOLLOW UP
AFTER THE COMMITTEE AND SEE
WHAT YOU ALL ARE WORKING ON AND
HOW WE MIGHT WORK TOGETHER
EARLY NEXT YEAR AND ASSIST YOU
IN. MAKING SOME PROGRESS THE.
GOOD AFTERNOON- MY NAME IS
ANOTHER SAVVY SO SOMETHING ON
I'M NEWLY ELECTED BOARD
PRESIDENT OF LIKE I SAID THAT I
SAID I WANT TO THANK UNITS HAVE
A MEAL. FOR A LIFTING UP THE
WORK THAT WE HAVE DONE- DURING
RECENT DISASTERS EVEN WHEN THE
SCHOOLS WERE ALL CLOSE WE WERE
THE ONE PLACE THAT WAS OPEN-
YOU KNOW PROVIDING FREE
CHILDCARE FOR A COMMUNITIES-
AND IT'S JUST A POINT THAT WE
ALL STRATEGICALLY. FIGURE OUT
HOW WE'RE GOING TO BE THERE FOR
THE PLACES THAT ARE TRUSTED
SPACES IN OUR COMMUNITY-
BECAUSE WE DON'T US EVEN THOUGH
WE DO ALL OF THIS WITH SO MUCH
LOVE. LOVE DOESN'T PAY TO KEEP
THE LIGHTS ON IT DOESN'T PAY TO
DO ALL THE EXTRA WORK THAT IT
TAKES TO DO THIS- AND ALSO I
WANT TO THANK PAT FOR YOUR
ANALYSIS AROUND. THIS BEING
SUCH UP UP BASIC ISSUE AROUND
CLIMATE CHANGE- AND I FEEL LIKE
IF WE DON'T ADDRESS THAT. ALL
OF WHAT WE DO AS A COLLECTIVE
IT'S GONNA BE BANDAIDS AND SO I
JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'RE ALSO LOOKING AT THIS- IN
A LARGER FRAME OF MIND BECAUSE
WE CAN'T KEEP DOING THIS OVER
AND OVER AND OVER AGAIN AND-
THEY KEEP IT EXACERBATED. AS AS
WELL IN YOUR HAND AND ALSO.
YEAH EXTRANET THE IN. MY
ORGANIZATION RUNS TWO ONE ONE
VENTURE AND WE COVER. UP TWENTY
ONE COUNTIES WITH TO ON
COVERAGE REALLY PLEASED TO
SUPPORT A SANTA BARBARA WE HAVE
FOR MANY YEARS- SO PARTIAL
SOLUTION. TO MY COLLEAGUE HERE
FROM BUCKET BRIGADE- I THINK
ONE OF THE CHALLENGES HERE IS
REALLY ACCESS. SO IF YOU CAN
NAME ALL OF THE PHONE NUMBERS
OF YOUR FAMILY MEMBERS. I WILL
BUY YOU A CUP OF COFFEE AFTER
THIS MEETING. I CAN'T DO THAT
WELL YOU CAN ARE AT. YOUR ON- I
CAN'T DO THAT AND THIS IS WHY
TWO ONE ONE IS REALLY- A
BRILLIANT SOLUTION FOR KNITTING
TOGETHER THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
ARE RESPONDING AND I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT WE'VE
BEEN TALKING A LOT ABOUT. THE
RECOVERY PHASE THE SECOND
PHASE. OF MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
BECAUSE THESE. DISASTERS ARE
TRIGGERING. MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
ACROSS THE COMMUNITY TWO ONE
ONE IS. RESPONDING TO THOSE
KINDS OF NEEDS HOUSING FOOD
MENTAL HEALTH. EVERY DAY OF THE
YEAR TWENTY FOUR HOURS A DAY.
AND THEN ALSO A DISASTER SO
THERE'S NO REASON WHY WE SHOULD
BE THINKING ABOUT. A SEPARATE
SYSTEM TO BE ABLE TO ENGAGE THE
PUBLIC- SO FROM VENTURA COUNTY
SORRY FOR BRINGING THE THOMAS
FIRE YOUR THIS WAY- WE DID THAT
THAT'S MY FAULT- BUT- WHAT-
WHAT WE'RE ABLE TO DO HOWEVER
IS TO REALLY. LINK PEOPLE WITH
THE RESOURCES THAT THEY NEED IN
THE DISASTER POSTERS ASTOR. AND
NOW FROM FOR THEIR SPECIAL
POPULATION AS WELL AS AS- WHAT
WE SAW YOU. THE I THINK FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES IN THE THOMAS FIRE
WHERE YOU HAD PEOPLE. EATING
WHO'VE NEVER REALLY HAD TO GO
TO ANY KIND OF SOCIAL SERVICE.
SYSTEM. FOR HELP BEFORE ON
THERE REALLY FISH OUT OF WATER
SO. THINK REALLY THAT ACCESS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN DO A LOT
WITH. AND WE ACTUALLY JUST
STARTED A DISASTER COMMUNITY
INFORMATION EXCHANGE SYSTEM AND
SO WERE WELCOMING ORGANIZATIONS
TO JOIN INTO THAT. THIS IS A
UNIQUE WAY TO BE ABLE TO- TO
COLLABORATE AND DO THAT KIND OF
CARE FOR CASE MANAGEMENT SO
FOLKS DON'T DROP- BETWEEN-
BETWEEN THE CRACKS. CHALLENGE
THINGS HAPPEN SO ARE OPEN TO
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE ABOUT
TWO ON ONE BUT I REALLY THINK
THIS IS SOMETHING WE- CAN
INVEST IN. ON 3% GOING UP TO
ABOUT 99% VERY QUICKLY OF THE
POPULATION IN CALIFORNIA HAS
ACCESS- ON A CELL PHONE
LANDLINE TO THEIR TWO ONE ONE
IN THEIR COMMUNITY. HELLO
EVERYONE OF LOS AFTER TODAY IT
WAS BORN AND GREW UP HERE IN
SANTA BARBARA. AND BACK IN THE
SIXTIES AS A KID I REMEMBER.
OUR FIRST DISASTER FIRE THE
COYOTE FIRE THAT WAS NINETEEN
SIXTY FOUR MEN OF THE PRINCES
SCHOOL AT THAT TIME. IN
SHAREPOINT BEEN THROUGH THE
FLOODS THE WORST QUAKE SINCE SO
FORTH BUT I'M GONNA CONCENTRATE
ON FIRES BECAUSE I DO REMEMBER.
AS A KID AND SEEING SOME
CONTROLLED BURNS OR ALSO KNOWN
I GUESS AS FUEL BRAKES. AGENCY
THAT. EVERY SO OFTEN IN THE
SIXTIES AND THROUGHOUT THE
SEVENTIES BUT NOT SO MUCH
MIDDLE. NOW DAYS. AND I'M JUST
WONDERING IF THIS IS STILL
GOING ON. AND I THINK. ALSO.
THAT MADE A PRETTY OWNERS THAT
HAVE A LOT OF EDUCATION IN THE
MUNCY IT'LL SYCAMORE BACK OF
THE RIVIERA SHOULD YOU KNOW
CLEAR THEIR VEGETATION. IT
WOULD BE 1100% PERFECT BUT IT
COULD SEEM HOMES COULD SAVE
LIVES SO I'M JUST. DURING THE
WEEK WE DO NEED SOME MORE
CONTROLLED BURNS IN OUR STATE
AND FOR PEOPLE WHO HAVE PROP
EIGHT WITH A LOT OF VEGETATION
TO CLEAR THAT OUT AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE. THAT'S IT. HI MANY IN
THAT IT GIVES THEM THE- HERE
I'M I'M HERE I CAN'T FIT ALL
THE MANY HOUSE ON ONE LABEL- I
THINK MY PRIMARY- ROLE HERE IS
AS A- MOM OF A SON WITH SPECIAL
NEEDS. AT THE MARIE BROUGHT UP.
YOU KNOW THE POWER OUTAGE ISSUE
IT'S A HEALTH ISSUE BUT IT'S
ALSO A COMMUNICATION ISSUE FOR
NON VERBAL- PEOPLE WHO DEPEND
ON DEVICES- FURTHER
COMMUNICATION- I WOULD I AM
ALSO HERE. A GRADUATE OF THE
FAMILY VOICES OF CALIFORNIA
LEADERSHIP PROJECT AND SERVE ON
A PARENT OR FAMILY ADVISORY
COMMITTEE AT SUN CAL AND SINCE
I HAVE YOU ALL IN ONE ROOM I
WOULD JUST ENCOURAGE YOU TO-
BRING IN THE VOICES OF THESE
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS WHO ARE
AFFECTED- IN THESE DISASTERS
AND IF YOU HAVE FAMILY ADVISORY
COMMITTEES- YOU KNOW INVITE.
INVITE US ALPHA RESOURCE CENTER
IS A GOOD RESOURCE. AND I WOULD.
I HAVE LOTS OF OTHER THINGS ON
MY MIND BUT THAT'S ALL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS PUBLIC COMMENT HERE
BEFORE WE WRAP UP. SEE A COUPLE
IN THE BACK HERE MIKE. HELLO
I'LL BE QUICK AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING THIS PANEL A VERY MUCH
ASSEMBLYMEMBERS- ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAY'S WANTED TO ADDRESS
YOUR QUESTION ABOUT HOW SOME OF
THESE THINGS WE'VE SPOKEN ABOUT
HERE OR OUR EXPERIENCES HERE IN
SANTA BARBARA COUNTY. COULD
HELP OTHER AREAS WITH DIFFERENT
RESOURCES WHETHER IT'S NOT
DIFFERENT ON PROFITS OR INCOME
LEVEL PER CAPITA- SO THE MONEY
CEDAR RECOVERY CENTER OF MUNCIE
TO CENTER RECOVERY. REBUILDING
IN BUSINESS. THAT COULD
ACTUALLY BE REPLICATED WORK
VERY WELL AS A HUB. IT DOESN'T
I DON'T THINK IT WOULD MATTER
WHAT INCOME LEVEL A COMMUTE THE
WHAT THERE WAS VACANT
COMMERCIAL SPACE THAT AN OWNER
COULD DONATE PROBABLY GET A TAX
WRITE OFF FOR IT- IN THIS CASE
THEY WITH THE SPACE WAS DONATED
FOR SIX MONTHS FROM NOW OR
FULLER FOUNDATION- SO- IT
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT TYPE OF
BUILDING IT IS OUR SPACES.
THERE'S AN EMPTY SPACE WITH
DIFFERENT OFFICES ARE DIFFERENT
AREAS THAT PEOPLE CAN COME
TOGETHER- HE'S HAVE VERY LOW
OVERHEAD AND HAVE A BIG BENEFIT
FOR YOUR RECOVERY. THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING EVERYBODY I'LL TRY
TO BE BRIEF. FOR THOSE OF YOU
THAT THAT'S PROBABLY DIFFICULT.
AND MY NAME IS MAGGIE TO GUESTS
AND THE EMERGING MANAGE TO
CHANNEL ISLANDS AND THE CHAIR
FOR VENTURE. I DON'T WORK VERY
CLOSELY WITH OUR SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA ABOUT WHAT SO SOME
OF THE QUESTIONS ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS I HAVE IS VERY
POINTED QUESTION PROBABLY IS
GOING TO BE GEARED TOWARD STAY
YES. BUT WE ARE. HAVE A VERY
ROBUST LONG TERM CAREER COUNTRY
GROUP. AND DURING THE THOMAS
FIRE HILL WILL BE FINE A
BORDERLINE INCIDENT WE WERE
VERY ACT. ARE ACTIVATED BY
COUNTY YES SIR. WE GET CALLS OR
SOMETHING THEN I A SEDAN EOC OR
SOMEONE ELSE DOES AND FROM THE
OUT SO WE'RE VERY VERY ACTIVE
SO I GUESS ONE OF THE POINTED
QUESTIONS I HAVE IS A FIRST OF
ALL YES WE LIVE EAT AND BREATHE
BY INCIDENT COMMAND SYSTEM I
ACTUALLY TEACH ICS SO IF
ANYBODY IS INTERESTED ON
TEACHING A CLASS ON. FRIDAY IN
CAMERI FROM NINE THIRTY TO
ELEVEN. SO JUST LET ME KNOW AND
I'LL PUT YOU ON THE LIST BUT
THE OTHER THING IS THAT YES AND
SOMEBODY SAID THAT BEAU ADS RUN
OFF A SHOE STRING BUDGET. I
WISH I HAD A SHOE STRING BUDGET
BECAUSE WE ON OUR MICROSCOPIC
BUDGET SO MOST OF THE MONEY THE
ACTIVITIES THAT WE- THE
TRAININGS THAT WE- SENDING
PEOPLE TO CONFERENCES TO
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA IS MOSTLY
DONE BY THOSE OF US THAT PULL
THE MONEY OUT OF OUR OWN
POCKET. SO FOR EXAMPLE NEXT
FRIDAY NOVEMBER FIRST I HAVE A
WORLD RENOWNED EXPERT IN
CENTIMETERS QUITE COMING DOWN
FOR GENERAL MEMBERSHIP MEETING
I'M PAYING FOR HER AIR FARE OUT
OF MY OWN POCKET. I WOULD LOVE
TO SEE IS THAT THERE IS A
POSSIBILITY THAT WE ASK
SOMEBODY COULD DIRECT. APPLY
FOR EVEN SEE THE MONEY. I MEAN.
WE DON'T HAVE POLO SHIRTS OR
ANYTHING TO EVEN GET US INTO A
DISASTER AREA IF I CALL MY INFO
AT PEOPLE. I MIGHT OFFICERS TO
CAMBER SPAHN. EVEN IF WE JUST
HAD A SMIDGE. I'M AND- GUIDANCE
ON HOW TO APPLY FOR THAT KIND
OF MONEY. THAT WOULD BE AWESOME
IT WOULD MAKE MY YEAR. THANK
YOU. DO YOU WANT TO GET A NEW
AB ONE OF QUICK RESPONSE TO
THAT. YEAH I'D LIKE TO HEAR THE
ANSWER. THAT IS THAT IS THE
THING THANK YOU. THAT IS ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I AM CONSTANTLY
HEARING IS FUNDING IT'S
THROUGHOUT THE STATE EVERY
LEVEL IT'S A FUNDING ISSUE
BECAUSE ALL OF THE VOTE LAZAR
ARE NON PROFITS AND THEIR
VOLUNTEER THEY DO THIS FOR
THEIR COMMUNITY FOR THE GOOD OF
THEIR COMMUNITY. AND THE LAST
THING THEY THINK ABOUT IS
GETTING MORE AND MORE FUNDING
SO WE ARE WORKING WITH AWAY
THREE CALIFORNIA TRYING TO COME
UP WITH WAYS THAT MAKE IT A BIT
EASIER TO APPLY FOR THESE
DIFFERENT KIND OF GRANTS OF THE
FOUNDATIONS OF CROSSES THE
COUNTRY. BUT ALSO OUR LOCAL AND-
COMMUNITY FOUNDATION CALIFORNIA
LEAGUE OF COMMUNITY FOUNDATIONS
OF. THE THERE'S A THERE'S AN
ASSOCIATION TO TALK ABOUT THAT
WELL AND THEY ARE ALSO. IN
LOOKING AT FEDERAL MONEY TO SEE
FIGURE OUT A WAY A IS FINAL
THAT INTO THE COMMUNITIES FOR
THE BOW ADDS BUT THAT'S A
THAT'S A LONG STRETCH SO WE'RE
TRYING TO LOOK AT THE PRIVATE
SECTOR AS WELL SO THAT THAT IS
ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I'M
WORKING ON. I DO KNOW THAT IT
IS A VERY VERY SENSITIVE AND
VERY TIMELY SUBJECT BECAUSE.
LIKE YOU THERE'S SIXTEEN WELL
ADS AND WE HAVE FIFTY EIGHT
COUNTS WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
BECAUSE OF COUNTIES WILL.
MISTER WE WANT. SO AND I WOULD
ADD ONE MORE THING- IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN WE PASS
AB TWENTY TWO FIFTY TWO- WHICH
IS A BILL THAT CONSOLIDATE ALL
GRANT PROGRAMS AND WILL BE
WILLING OF CALIFORNIA'S VERSION
OF GRANT STOCK UP WITH THE
FEDERAL. GOVERNMENT HAS AND
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO. GO ON LINE
NEXT SUMMER SO IT IS NOT AN
IMMEDIATE SOLUTION BUT
UNDERSTAND THAT. NONPROFITS
HAVE RAISE THIS ISSUE ABOUT
WHERE TO APPLY FOR FUNDING FOR
SO MANY. THAT WE DO TO HAVE
THAT. BUT IT HAS TAKEN OUR
STATE A NUMBER OF YEARS TO TRY
TO GET THAT UP. THE BILL WAS AB
TWENTY TWO FIFTY TWO. ALL ADD
TO THAT IN THAT I'M. BIG ON
TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE IN. STATE
IN A CROSS SECTION VERY AS WE
TALKED ABOUT THIS BEFORE BUT
HOUSING TALK ABOUT
TRANSPORTATION. TOO OFTEN. WE
TAKE. WE GO WHERE THERE'S HOLD
IT'S A GREAT. I DON'T KNOW WHAT
THE SITUATION HERE IS IN SANTA
BARBARA- I CAN TELL YOU IN THE
CITY ABOUT WATER IN MY DISTRICT
THE CITY MANAGER CHIEF REPLACE
THE SAME PERSON MUCH LESS. IS.
YOUR DEPLOYMENT OKAY.
SPECIFICALLY THOUGH SO THAT
WILL FOLLOW UP WITH YOU MIGHT
CAN YOU MAKE SURE WE GET- HER
INFORMATION THANK YOU NEXT
QUESTION HELLO EVERYONE AS WE
MEMBERS THANK YOU FOR HOSTING
US TODAY AND PANELISTS THANKS
FOR SPEAKING- MY NAME IS GREG
YOUNG AND I'M PART OF THE CLEAN
COLLECTION- OUR MISSION IN LIFE
IS TO SORRY TO TRANSITION TO
RUN AWAY ENERGY IN A MODERN
GREAT. AND WE DO THAT'S OUR
TECHNICAL POLICY AND PROGRAM
DEVELOPMENT WORK WERE VERY
HEAVILY FOCUSED ON COMMITTEE MY
COURAGE RIGHT NOW- AND TO
ALLUDE TO SHARON BURNS COMMENT
EARLIER WHEN SHE STEPPED OUT-
WITH LEE IN THE FOREFRONT OF
MODESTY TOOK ME MARKER
INITIATIVE PAIRED WITH- THE
WORK IS ACADEMY- MERCY TO COME
YOU MAKER INITIATIVE- SINCE
AIMS TO PROVIDE INDEFINITE
RENEWAL WAS DRIVEN BACK UP
POWER- ESSENTIALLY STARTING
WITH MY ZERO FIRE DISTRICT
MARCY WATER DISTRICT AND THE
INTIMACY IN SCHOOL- IN THIS IS
TABLETS THROUGH SOLAR AS WELL
AS- AND YOU STORAGE AT THEIR
SITES. THOSE THOSE ESSENTIALLY
THREE SITES AS MY GRADES IN MY
ZERO CAN YOU MAKE YOUR
INITIATIVE- ARE THE FAIREST
ESSENTIAL BUILDING BLOCKS TO
OUR BIGGER VISION ARE BIGGER
INITIATIVE WHICH IS. THE
LEILA'S POCKET COMMITTEE MAKER
IT- IN THE CLEAR LOW POCKET TO
GIVE- FURTHER EXPLANATION WHAT
THAT IS- IT'S A SEVENTY MILE
STRETCH COASTLINE IN THE
SOUTHERN SANTA BARBARA COUNTY
AREA- FROM POINT CONCEPTION TO
WAKE AT CEDARS. AND CONSISTING
OF THE MAJOR LOADS OF BEING THE
LEAD- SANTA BARBARA AND
CORPORATE RIA- AND THE
CLEVELAND PARK COMMITTEE MAKER
INITIATIVE- AIMS TO. PROVIDE
THE AREA- ECONOMIC
ENVIRONMENTAL AND RESILIENCE
BENEFITS. RESILIENCE BEING. THE
KEY POINT IN THIS CONVERSATION
TODAY. WE NEED ESSENTIALLY WE
DON'T IN ALICE'S WHEN YOU
ESSENTIALLY TWO HUNDRED
MEGAWATTS OF SOLAR. AND FORMER
MEGAWATT HOURS OF ENERGY
STORAGE- THAT IS CURRENTLY
ABOUT FIVE TIMES MORE SOLAR
THAT WE NEED TO THAT IS
CURRENTLY ALREADY INSTALLED IN
IN SOUTHERN ST BARBARA COUNTY
NUCLEOLAR PARKING AREA. AND IS
IT ABOUT- 7% OF THE TECHNICAL
STUDY POTENTIAL- SO YOU KNOW ON
BILL ENVIRONMENTS WE SEE THAT
BEING THE BEST LOCAL. BEING AS
YOU SO IS BEING SO A- AND BEING
ON THOSE ENVIRONMENTS THERE
THERE'S MEGA LOTS OF POTENTIAL
WE SEE IN THIS AREA- SO IT'S
BEST TO ORDER MY GLASSES SO IS
ABOUT 7% OF THAT CITING
POTENTIAL- SO IT GIVEN THERE IS
EXTREMELY VULNERABLE TO- TO
ENVIRONMENT DISASTERS WE HAVE
ONE TRANSMISSION LINE THAT RUNS
THROUGH THE SCENE IS BENITO
FROM VENTURA TO SENTENCING IS
MOUNTAINS AND IN DOWN TO THE
WE'VE SUBSTATION WHICH IS JUST
OFF OF GRANT A ROAD- AND
ESSENTIALLY IS IN THE IS THIS
THE NAME SAKE FOR THE CLEVELAND
POCKET. THE REASON WHY IT'S
CALLED AS BECAUSE IT'S NAMED
AFTER THE ONLY TRANSMISSION TO
DISTRIBUTION SUBSTATION. WE
HAVE AN AREA WHICH IS THE
PLEASE UPDATE. IS IT AT ONE
TRANSMISSION LINES EXTREMELY
VULNERABLE TO FIRE MUD SLIDES
EARTHQUAKES- AND GIVEN THE
EVENT OF THOSE SCENARIOS. THE
GORILLAPOD COMMITTEE MAKER
WOULD PROVIDE A 100% RESILIENCE
TO TRANSMISSION OUTAGE- AND
THEN AS WELL GIVEN THE RECENT
PS PS VENTS- THE P. S. P. S.
EVENTS YOU KNOW. I HAVE SEEN IN
ACROSS CALIFORNIA BUT
SPECIFICALLY HERE IN THIS
REGION- THE GLEE LÀ PACKET CAM
YOU MARKER WOULD PROVIDE. US
RESILIENCE TO THOSE EVENTS. ONE
MORE COMMENT I'LL BE FINISHED-
GREEN COLLISION RECENTLY IS
WORKING WITH THE CITY OF
CALISTOGA- SO THE CAT CITY OF
CAL SERVICE IS UP IN THE NORTH
KID NORTHERN CALIFORNIA AREA- A
FEW MONTHS AGO THEY HAD A-
FORTY EIGHT HOUR. PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF. THE DAY AFTER
THE CALL THE CLEAN COLLISION.
WE ARE NOW YOU KNOW DESIGNING
DEVELOPING A COULD YOU MAKE A
GOOD FOR THEIR FOR THEIR CITY-
COULD BE ALSO DOWN HERE IN THE
IN THE GLOBAL YOU CAN YOU MAKE
YOUR GOOD. CHARACTER. THANK YOU
ALSO ONE WOULD EXPECT WE ARE
SEVEN ASSEMBLY BILL- THIRTEEN
THIRTY NINE THERE'S ALSO
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN THIRTY
NINE AT THE CBC FOLKS AROUND- A
MAKER IT'S MARGARET PROCEEDING-
AND WE'VE BEEN COMMENTS
RECENTLY REGARDING THAT I'M
MORE THAN WELCOME TO SHARE
COMMENTS. THANKS OKAY THE- OUR
OF TWELVE THIRTY HAVING ARRIVED
WHERE THIRTY MINUTES BEYOND OUR
TIME FRAME HERE'S WILL TAKE ONE
MORE QUESTION- OR COMMENT AND
THEN WE'RE GONNA WRAP UP. I'M
SITES YOU TO CLARIFY THE RECORD
AT CORY HAMMOND I'M ON THE
BOTTOM LINE IS HERE WATER
DISTRICT WE DO NOT HAVE A
CONTRACT WITH THE MICRO GET
ORGANIZATION THIS POINT TIMES I
NEED A- CLEAR RECORD. THAT'S
ALL THANKS FOR WHAT YOU DO.
THANK YOU SO MUCH LET'S GET
ANOTHER ROUND OF APPLAUSE FOR
OUR PANELISTS. DISCLOSURE TO
MAKE SOME CLOSING REMARKS I
JUST WANT TO THANK EVERYONE FOR
PARTICIPATING THIS HAS BEEN A
REALLY GOOD TWO AND A HALF
HOUR- DISCUSSION AND I
APPRECIATE ALL THE PARTICIPANTS
AND- ASSEMBLY MEMBER. THANK YOU
FOR COMING TO SANTA BARBARA- TO
HEAR A LITTLE BIT FROM OUR
DISTRICT SOME OF THE WORK WE
ARE DOING WE WILL BE. FOLLOWING
UP AND I IN THE FORM OF THE
LEGISLATIVE CONVERSATIONS AND
PERHAPS POLICY- AS THE NEW
LEGISLATIVE YOUR PURCHASE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU ALL